This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotopi is presented by CVS. It just came out. Jeremy, what did you just do? You just sit yourself up for failure. I've never heard you tell this story. I've never told this story. This must have been tucked deep, deep into Jeremy Linfile.
My name is MC Jin. I'm excited to tell you about laugh but not least. I'll be chatting with guests from all walks of life about the power of humor when it comes to facing difficult times. These will be conversations that remind us all. Life is hard. Laugh harder. Listen, and laugh but not least with MC Jen. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
or wherever you get your podcast. Happy Pride from the Outspoken Podcast Network. All month long and all year round, we're celebrating being loud, proud, and always original. It's me, Brandon Kyle Goodman, host of the podcast, Tell Me Something Messy. Check out my show for unfiltered takes on dating, relationships, and adulting.
Listen to High Key for the best pop culture takes, and there are no girls on the internet for all your tech news. For your favorite celebrity key keys, check outlaws with T.S. Madison. Learn to love yourself unapologetically with BFF, Black Fat Fem, and start your day with intention with waking up with Ryan coming in July. Celebrate Pride with the Outspoken Network. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Pride and listen now. This Black Music Month, the Questlove show celebrates the visionaries, shaping culture through sound. From country trailblazer Mickey Gaiden to hip-hop icon Fat Five Freddy, the sonic genius of Thundercat, and the revolutionary voice of Chuck D.
I want it loud. So the timing might be off, the sound might be muffled, but what's going to come out of there is something that you can feel. Celebrate Black Music Month with special episodes of the Questlove show. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to Sabara Football, the sweet and the spicy on and off the field. I'm Daniela Durand, and this is where we get to know the people behind the game like never before. The pressure, the fame, and everything that happens when the cameras turn off.
Enjoy conversations with guests like Barbartra, Ennard Valencia, Sharon Escobar, Pollo Diceno, Federeira, and many more. Only Santos Aura Football on the Aija Radio app, Apple Podcast, or whatever you get your podcast. Before we begin today's episode, I just want to note that this conversation includes discussions around suicide, grief, and mental health. Please just take care while listening, and if anything has brought up some heavy or difficult feelings today, reach out to somebody you trust or seek support. from a mental health professional or crisis service in your area. As always, we will have links and resources in the description. You do not have to go through these hard moments alone. So please reach out to somebody that you love.
Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today's episode is a really special one because we are joined by someone whose work has opened up some incredibly important conversations around mental health, grief, masculinity, vulnerability for, if I'm being honest, an entire generation of young people. Today I'm joined by Ben West. You may know him through his advocacy work following the loss of his younger brother.
Since then, he's launched his movement reasons to stay to help guide strangers through difficult times. But beyond that, beyond the public work, Ben is also somebody who is deeply thoughtful. He has an amazing perspective on being human, on friendship, purpose, pain and hope. And we are so excited to have him on. Ben, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Thank you so much for having me here. I'm so excited for this chat. Yeah.
And it took you a second to get here. We're recording it on a day of a crazy tube strike. They have rid. All the transport into London was just, nope, today is not my day. And, you know, it's funny when you work in mental health, you're constantly talking about, like, coping and relieving stress. And then suddenly all the trains are stuck and you're having to, like, practice what you preach and try not to get frazzled by London transport.
I'm here. You came in cool, calm and collected. Inside. I'm like a duck. Yeah, you're just like, ha. Legs are going under the water. Well, this is the thing that I've found since moving to London is I've become very angry. and I have to really kind of rain it in.
Yeah, just the smaller stuff. I'm like, the world is a terrible awful place. I know. And then the weather as well. It's always all comes together. You've got wind, rain, trains are late. Someone spills coffee on you. Yeah, or worse.
Or it's really difficult to try and get out of that funk. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And then like a light is flickering and you're like, I just want to lay down. Yeah. And you know what? I used to be, not to go straight in with the psychology, but I used to be really bad at having that happen and then immediately writing off the day and getting into a bad mood. And it actually came up when I was going through therapy, like that, like bad days would
just take over and become bad days. And it was that, it was that experience that actually I started my first rule I have with myself, which is that if it's a bad day, you have to do something good, right? And so it was something we came up with in therapy, which was like I always just had, So as soon as bad things happen, I just form the mindset that it was a bad day. And so I have this rule where you have to do something good. So that's something simple like talking to a shopkeeper in the shops or texting a friend you haven't spoken to in a while or just doing something good or being happy to see someone. And then as soon as you've done that, you've taken the power away from the bad day. So not to go straight in with psychology, but this is actually very relevant to something that I love it. It's one of my two important rules that I live by. Okay, well, I have two follow-up questions. Number one is what are you going to do today? I haven't decided yet.
I feel like this is quite a good thing to do. Oh, okay. Well, this is work. This can be my... Yeah, no, I think I'm going to an event later, which will be really good. So I think that will be my good thing for today. And that's supporting an amazing charity, and it's going to be such a lovely evening. So I feel like that will be my good thing today.
But even if it's just literally going into the shops and forcing herself to get into shops and then talk, actually talk to the person at the checkout, always makes the day better. Yeah. And what's your second rule? My second rule is because of the nature of my job, and we'll get into this, I talk to a lot of people about some really awful stuff. And so my other rule is that I'm still thinking about a conversation two weeks later. I have to talk to someone about it.
I don't give myself the choice because, you know, some of the conversations I have with people are fairly harrowing. And usually I'm quite good at processing that. But yeah, if I'm still thinking about it, I was thinking about them two weeks later, I have to talk someone about that conversation. And it just takes my choice away. So I know then I'm like, it's been two weeks. I need to text my counsellor.
I need to go and book some time in and talk about this. Yeah. It sort of takes that opportunity to push the can down the road away from me. I used to have this one. I used to do, we are going in. Oh my God. I used to do interviews for the Australian government on child maltreatment. Wow.
And as in like calling people up and being like, you know. tell me about what you've been through. And I was so young, I wish I had that rule. Because my rule was just like if I had a bad call, I'd go and eat a kind of Bueno. Yes. And I think that probably made much, they've got into a really bad habit. Yeah, it's like classic conditioning. You're going to stop wanting those, right?
I was just going to say that even now, like thinking of it yesterday, I had a bad day and I went and got a kind of Bueno. And I was like, oh, we cannot go back down this road again. You're a conditioned to want a kind of Bueno. Yeah, texting counsellor, kind of Bueno. So, let's see. I love a Kinderbano, though. I know, it's so good.
Can you briefly, you know what? I did not even ask you to introduce yourself. That's okay, we've gone straight in. Can you briefly introduce yourself? Tell us a little bit about who you are as a person, how people might know you or they don't know you who you are. Yeah, absolutely. So my name's Ben.
I am a mental health campaign. The fact that I'm introducing myself as a mental health campaign is still weird because it's not something I ever thought I'd have to do. Growing up, I didn't know anything about mental health. No one had ever talked to me about mental health. And the first time it really came up in my life was when my mom told me that my little brother, Sam, had been diagnosed with depression. And that was the first time I'd ever really heard what that was. I didn't really know anything more about it. So I never spoke to Sam. And then, very sadly, in January 2018, Sam took his own life and died at the age of 15 years old and I was 17.
And obviously through that experience, I very quickly realized that the significance of what my mum had told me in September and also free speaking to my friends and people at school realized like how many people were affected by this sort of thing. And my plan in life at that moment was to go to university, study engineering and then go to the armed forces and fly helicopters, right? So that was my plan. Very Prince Harry coded. I know very.
And it's not what I'm doing, as you can tell. But I realised very quickly that, you know, what happened to Sam shouldn't have happened. And there were small things that could have been different. And it felt like I had a opportunity to change those small things for other people and pick up this sort of baton that Sam left behind in terms of wanting to create change and do my best. So I'm a mental health campaign and I've been doing this for eight years. people probably if you've heard my name you've probably heard it in association with my project that I launched this year called reasons to stay which I'm sure we'll get into more but essentially it's a suicide prevention project sending letters to people thinking about suicide giving them reasons to stay but you know my work
goes far beyond that the reason I'm dressed so smartly is I've been I work in policy so I do a lot of work with the government around NHS and healthcare for people with mental health and education and mental health So basically mental health is what I live and breathe. It's not something that I ever thought I'd go into, but it's something, you know, it is everything I do. And, you know, every day I think about Sam and what happened to him and my family. And I go to work because we absolutely, I absolutely believe that we can change this system that lets so many people down. And that's what I'm going to do for the rest of my life. That's what I've decided.
This is all I'm going to do. Wow. Yeah, which is a huge thing to say, but I love it is. But you had such pride in your eyes when you said that. Yeah. Can you tell me a bit about Sam and like some of your memories about him and like what kind of, what he was like? Yeah. Oh, Sam was wonderful.
He was very funny. And the sort of humor he had was like, you didn't know quite whether you were allowed to laugh. It was always just like on the edge of something really dark and awful. He had quite a dark sense of humour, but it was just so funny. Even his friends, like at school, they always said he was such a class clown. He'd try and make the whole class laugh. He was very, very talented in art and music. So, like, he was 15 when he was, you know, basically producing the whole film scores on his laptop.
Wow. Loved Hans Zimmer and film and film scores and music and film. he was also like he painted a lot and just the most phenomenal painter. And one of my favorite, yeah, one of my favorite memories back then of us as, because it was me, Sam and another brother, Tom, who's my youngest brother. And we used to just, Sam would do like some art and he'd just bring us in on right at the end to like help with something. And we were absolutely terrible.
I'm so jealous of Sam's talent with art because I can't draw. I can't paint. I would love to be able to paint, but I can't. I struggle so much with it. But he was very, very talented. But I think the big thing with Sam
that means a lot now looking back is he just had, he was like an emotional sponge. He just absorbed all the emotion around him. He was such an empath and he cared so much about other people. And that sense of like social, justice of if someone was being picked on or bullied, he would feel so like powerfully that that was unjust. He'd take a lot of that emotion on, which obviously must have been a lot for him to take on his
shoulders. But he just had this really strong sense of right and wrong. He was felt emotions and he felt other people's emotions really strongly, which, you know, obviously meant that when he was struggling. You felt very passionately about other people, you know, feeling seen as well through their struggles. And that's sort of why I feel like I want to do what I do now is because when he was struggling, he wanted other people to feel understood and for things to be better for them. And he never got the chance to sort of do this. And I know that absolutely if Sam had survived, he would have gone on to become a mental health campaigner. He probably was sitting in this chair talking to you. He would have done a phenomenal job. And I always say to people, I'm like,
unfortunately, you have got the second best option. But I will, I will do my absolutely best to sort of do what I think Sam would want to do. And that is to show up, to tell our story, be vulnerable, be honest, make people feel seen, but also, you know, push for the change that stops people getting support and stops people getting an education. So, yeah, I've tried to be better at art. And I've trying to be better music. But I know that one talent and one, one thing that me and sound absolutely share is that absolute social justice, right and wrong, empathy for, for people that don't deserve to feel the way they do and not have the support that so many people don't have nowadays. I feel like, does your younger brother have that as well? Yeah. We all do. I was going to say,
I feel like that would be a very strong through line from like your parents. Yeah. I, I I definitely think so. And they've, in my parents have obviously reacted in a similar way to say I'm dying in terms of like trying to change. Yeah. Change things and provide support, which a lot of people do when when something awful happens. And it's nice that we're all sort of on the same page of that was so bad that we're going to make sure it never happens again. We're all very aligned on that. I saw this interesting thing from Jack Antonoff.
Do you know who that is? No. Okay, he's a music producer. Not important. But he said that when you're experiencing. in grief is when your purpose becomes the clearest because nothing else matters. And that kind of sounds like that's what's happened to you, you know, through that. Yeah, definitely.
I think there's so many reasons why I do what I do now, but one of them is definitely that it hurts so much that I think pain without a meaning is very difficult to cope with because it feels like what is this all for? I mean, and it hurts so much. It's still, you know, it's still a horrible, horrible thing to have gone through. And it doesn't make it less painful, but it does make that experience feel like it's worth something. And, you know, I get the absolute privilege of hearing from people
who have been, you know, materially changed and helped by work that I've been involved in or contributed to. and I remember a little 17 year old me sat at school with my friends trying to work out what we were going to do to change the world and over time you realise that actually changing the world and creating that much impact in reality happens in really quiet moments with people and if you can stop one person from taking their own life or you get the right support to one person the ripple effect of that over time is absolutely enormous. And so, you know, like I remember just thinking back now to the 17 or me not knowing what I was meant to do or how I was going to turn this awful
who have been, you know, materially changed and helped by work that I've been involved in or contributed to. and I remember a little 17 year old me sat at school with my friends trying to work out what we were going to do to change the world and over time you realise that actually changing the world and creating that much impact in reality happens in really quiet moments with people and if you can stop one person from taking their own life or you get the right support to one person the ripple effect of that over time is absolutely enormous. And so, you, know, like I remember just thinking back now to the 17 or me not knowing what I was meant to do or how I was going to turn this awful
experience into something that was good. He would not believe what we've done over the last eight years. It's been the most extraordinary, powerful, meaningful journey. And I can say that now with a smile on my face. Like it has, my story is so sad. had but it's got to a position now where it's a really happy positive journey and that I didn't I didn't believe that was ever possible so that's that's pretty that's pretty is the wrong way no it's yeah I know and it's only sometimes that you actually reflect and go yeah there were you know when sam died I honestly I didn't think anything good would ever happen to me again I don't know how to describe it except that I just thought my life was always going to be great.
Yeah. And I just didn't think anything would be fun or funny or positive. And so it's quite profound to be able to sit here now and say, this is great. I love what I do. I feel joy almost every day. And that's been quite the journey to get there. But it's very meaningful.
Experience. You end up how with weekend gold tickets to Lassau Montreal Thomas Rhett Mumford and Suss Well here's my pride And here's my shame
John Party Old Dominion Carly Pierce and more And the prize gets even sweeter With flights from Porter Airlines Three nights at Residence in Downtown Montreal And $1,000 cash
Download the free IHeart Radio app Listen to Pure Country for 10 minutes And enter to win Lasso Montreal Every Day you listen It's another chance to win Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby.
Okay, if you know me, you know this. I'm always searching for inspiration, for support, and useful tools to help maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover all of that together. We're going to have these meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges that she never saw coming. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Olympic champ Sean Johnson revealed why she had no choice but to be a gymnast.
There was something about gymnastics that was intoxicating to me. It's given me a belief that we all have one of those treasures inside of us. We just have to find it. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Mungesha Chitigather, and I'm back with a new season of the podcast Skyline Drive. This time I'm diving into a rabbit hole of peptides, organoids, blood boys, blue zones, and brain replacement to try to understand what this longevity obsession is all about and what it really means to live forever for all of us. I learned about some rad science.
I can make a brain for you, and then we can test what draw is the best for you. brain, a supposed to his brain. Here are some hard truths. I would expect Indians to age faster, but I did not expect it to be almost a four to five year acceleration. And get myself into a world of trouble. I'd say probably start bones smashing. That doesn't work.
To make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are?
I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. Like, that's the rate we got to be going. Yep, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddy. I directed whenaz's early videos.
Which one? One love. Wow. I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. Nans was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff,
and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the Civil War.
To get to school, I had to go down Robert Ely Boulevard. Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spiritsy. Season two goes deep on both of those things, the fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean.
Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And you know what? I'm sure somebody's listening to this right now who's probably in the early stages of grief being like, this is always going to be it. And I think it's just a really nice thing to hear somebody say that. Even people with like a bit of anticipatory grief as well, probably listening being like, oh, like, yeah. Can I actually ask you about that a little bit more? Like I think you explained it very well. But how has your grief changed? Like when you first, I'm guessing, found out through your mom or through. a parent to that first year to now. Like what's been the different things that you've learned throughout the years about loss? Yeah. I mean, losing Sam was not only awful in terms of the grief of losing a brother that you didn't expect, obviously, but also through how he died and suicide. It was incredibly traumatic for me, particularly.
And so actually at the beginning, it's very difficult to determine. like what was grief and what was trauma, trauma response. But I, you know, I was, I was very affected at the beginning. Like, didn't know what was up or down. I felt like I was just stuck in this washing machine that was constantly on different cycles of all over the place, didn't sleep very much. I didn't eat for about four days.
I just was so confused. And my body was, I was like rejecting what I'd gone on. It was like, it's so bad. that you just reject what happened. So the point where, like, I went to school the day after Sam died. Did you really? Yeah. Were your teachers?
Yeah, they were completely shocked to see me. Yeah. What about your friends? Were they? Yeah. Yeah. I'm pretty sure they just thought it because everyone at school had been told that day. Yeah.
They probably thought, like, what is this sick joke? Ben's just, honestly, I got in my car and I went to school and I went in and I went in, and I just ran over to my friends and I was like, hey, how's everyone doing? Like nothing had happened because my brain was just like, nope. This is not, this has not happened. I'm going to do what I'd normally do and just take myself to school. And I lasted about an hour and then I was exhausted. Yeah, the adrenaline and shock just wearing off.
They probably thought, like, what is this sick joke? Ben's just, honestly, I got in my car and I went to school and I went in, and I just ran over to my friends and I was like, hey, how's everyone doing? Like nothing had happened because my brain was just like, nope. This is not, this has not happened. I'm going to do what I'd normally do and just take myself to school. And I lasted about an hour and then I was exhausted. Yeah, the adrenaline and shock just wearing off.
Yeah, but it was like that for a while. And then you slowly learn. And I think the best way I can describe it, and I've described it to other people is that, like, it's a flame, it's like a fire, like a bomb fire, when grief, you're standing so close to it that you can't notice anything but this intense heat that's coming from it. And everyone says time heals. It's not as straightforward as that. But I do think with time, you just get distance from the flame, that fire, so that it's still there and sometimes you notice it, but the heat, the feeling of the intensity of that heat just feels less and less extreme. So it's not the pain,
that makes you notice that this happened, but it's just sort of going into a room. You haven't been into you since he died, or the things would remind you it's there. I think that's the best way I've had to describe. It's just the intensity of those feelings, starts to just get less and less extreme with time. And that's definitely what I felt.
And then I eventually got the courage to seek professional support, which was scary, but amazing. and then dealt with a lot of the trauma that I had not really dealt with and EMDR therapy which I thought was amazing and I managed to do with a lot of that and then you get a position where you know you actually feel like you've got a handle back on things and and you because I think a lot of the time I was maybe in the passenger seat yeah and not really fully in control of what was going on and just sort of going from moment to moment. Actually, interestingly, not to go off on points, but one of the funny experience of
grief that I had, not funny, but like unexpected. A chuckle almost. Was hedonism, like this absolute intense need for fun and like just, I started university in like September, so a few months after Sam died and it was literally just like chasing fun and going out and like trying to just basically block everything out having just hedonistic out there like behavior which I think is so interesting because at the time I thought that I was doing really well yeah because I was having fun and I looked back and I was like I was actually just like chasing thrills trying to escape like feeling on my own or feeling low and that was an interesting that was an interesting observation I did not see in the time so years later I was like whoa I was really unwell when that was what happened.
And probably a lot of drinking. Oh, yeah. And it's also that's just like the, imagine being, well, you don't have to imagine. You're like, how old were you 18 at Fresh's Week? I don't know if you guys call it that. Just being like, oh week, just being like great. I have this gaping emotional wound and I have a gallon of liquor. Yeah.
Seems like I'm- And everyone around you is having a great, and that looks like the normal thing to do. Yeah. But like, wow. When do you think you came out of like the hedonistic? Like, oh, I'm just. going to live while I'm young stage. Do you think it was like after your first year or? I think it was COVID lockdown. So what's that? Three years, two, two and a half three years afterwards.
And when you're forced to not do that anymore. And I was on my own in COVID. So I was in a flat that was about, it's probably not much bigger than the studio. And I had to do 10 days on my own. And oh, that was tough. That was really. Was it just, did you have? I had, I got infected. You got infected. So I was stuck and then on my own. I remember the only person I saw in 10 days was someone pushed batteries for an Xbox controller
当你被迫不再那样做时。我在疫情期间独自一人。当时我住在一间公寓里，大概……可能比这个工作室大不了多少。我不得不独自度过10天。哦，那太难了。真的太难了。是吗？只有你一个？我有，我感染了。你感染了。所以我被困在那里，然后独自一人。我记得那10天里我见过的唯一一个人，是有人把一个Xbox手柄的电池
through past the door. Were you? We were at uni? Yeah. You were in like a dorm room. In like a little room. And that was, that was intense. And so I thought that whole experience, like, I actually was okay.
从门缝塞了进来。你在吗？我们是在读大学吗？对。你就像住在宿舍里一样。在一个小房间里。那感觉，那感觉真是太强烈了。所以我觉得整个经历，其实我还挺好的。
I was fine. I like coped. I was okay. but it just made you sort of, it took you away from everything that you usually kept to like make yourself okay. And I was very lucky that I had support through counselling at that time that I was doing virtually. So I was like, you start to go, oh, this sort of thing that I've popped myself up on that's fun.
我挺好的。我挺过来了。我还好。但这只是让你觉得，它把你从你平时用来让自己感觉良好的所有习惯中剥离了出来。我很幸运，当时我通过在线心理咨询得到了支持，所以我当时想，哦，你开始觉得，哦，我一直用来支撑自己的、觉得挺开心的这种东西，
Oh, it's not there anymore. I'm actually really really not okay. So that was quite an interesting experience for me. Just being forced to stay in my room. And then I left uni. Oh, yeah, because this is not happening. This is actually, now I've stepped out of this. I'm really not very well.
哦，它不在了。我其实真的、真的不太好。所以对我来说，那是一段相当有趣的经历。仅仅是被迫呆在我的房间里。然后我离开了大学。哦，对，因为这根本行不通。这实际上，现在我跳出了这个环境。我真的感觉很不舒服。
And then I left and sort of started to make some real changes in my life to sort of get back in control. So actually it was like, it was quite a good experience in a way. It sounds like a bit of a circuit breaker. It was, yeah, in a weird way. It wouldn't recommend it was a weird way. But it was like, it was also needed. Yeah. Because you started doing a lot of reflection on how I was living and what I was doing
然后我离开了，并开始在生活中做出一些真正的改变，以重新掌控生活。所以从某种意义上说，这其实是一次相当不错的经历。听起来有点像是一个断路器。是的，从某种奇怪的角度来说是这样的。我不会推荐这种方式，这是一种很奇怪的方式。但它也是必需的。是的。因为你开始对我是怎么生活的以及我在做什么进行了大量的反思，
and not really dealing with anything. And then it was like, hmm, this is an interesting moment of noticing all of that. Yeah. And then like another deeply traumatic moment probably where it's like, great. So my, this life that I'm trying to rebuild is going to be completely ripped apart. And we'll move on to the next thing. Yeah. And it was very confusing as well because I was in the moment of all of the plans I had in my life of what I wanted to do.
而没有真正去处理任何事情。然后我就想，嗯，这是一个有趣的时刻，注意到了这一切。是的，然后可能又是另一个非常痛苦的时刻，就像是，太好了。所以，我正试图重建的这个生活，将被彻底撕裂。然后我们将进入下一阶段。是的。这也非常令人困惑，因为当时我还在规划我生活中所有想做的事情，
I was still sort of doing because it was too late to change my degree or whatever. So I was like still on that plan but realizing more and more that it's not really what I wanted to do. And so there was a whole, it was just very confusing. Very, very confusing. Do you remember like the first time after Sam passed away that you and your family? like we're like together and we're like laughing and we're able to like have a bit of a glimmer. That's a really good question. That's a really good question.
我其实还在按计划进行，因为要改变学位什么的已经太晚了。所以我还在按那个计划走，但越来越意识到这并不是我真正想做的事。所以整个过程，非常令人困惑。非常、非常困惑。你还记得山姆去世后，你和家人第一次……就像我们在一起，像是在笑，并且能够看到一丝希望的光芒，是什么时候吗？这是一个很好的问题。这是一个很好的问题。
It took a long, a long time to feel normal as a family. You know, so many times you'd go and lay the table and you'd carry like five sets of forks and knives over or five like set places. And that happened so many times to me. And even like, talking about him took a long time to feel normal.
作为一个家庭，花了很长、很长的时间才感觉恢复正常。你知道，有很多次，你去摆放餐桌，会习惯性地拿五套刀叉过来，或者是摆五个人的位置。这种事发生在我身上很多次。甚至像谈论他，也花了很长的时间才感觉正常。
I don't actually remember, I think it might have been Christmas, weirdly, because that's quite difficult time for grief, when you can sort of get a little bit of room. I was also actually, it was probably not. So when I was at school, when Sam died,
其实我不记得了，我想奇怪的是，那可能是在圣诞节，因为对于悲伤来说，那是一段相当艰难的时期，当你能够从中获得一点喘息的空间时。我也觉得其实，可能不是。所以当我在上学时，山姆去世了，
I realized very quickly that I wanted to do something positive. And so I organised something called walk to talk, which was basically this 200km walk. that me and my friends were going to do to raise money. And we would invite the whole school. And if people wanted to come and walk the whole thing, they could come. If they wanted to walk one day, they could come and walk with us. And I basically designed it to be fun and colorful and real celebration of talking and mental health,
我很快意识到我想做一些积极的事情。所以我组织了一个名为“边走边聊”（walk to talk）的活动，基本上是一场200公里的徒步。我和朋友们打算借此筹集资金。我们邀请了全校的人。如果有人想走完全程，他们可以来。如果他们只想走一天，也可以来和我们一起走。我基本上把它设计成了一个充满乐趣、色彩斑斓、真正赞美交流和心理健康的活动，
as opposed to it being like a ceremony. And that was great. Like we had bright pink T-shirts and we were like talking about Sam every day. And it was fun. And my family got involved loads. So I think that was probably a good moment where we could really just sort of, I don't know, feel sort of, feel like the subject of suicide and losing Sam wasn't necessarily this dark, awful thing that we can't go near. It's like, actually, we're all dressed in pink having a good time talking about Sam and talking about something that's positive and getting around that. So that was a really, that was a nice moment.
而不是把它办成一个仪式。这真的很棒。我们穿着亮粉色的T恤，每天都在谈论山姆。这很有趣。我的家人也大量参与其中。所以我觉得那可能是一个很好的时刻，让我们能够真正地，怎么说呢，感觉自杀这个话题以及失去山姆，并不一定是一个我们不能触碰的黑暗、可怕的事情。相反，其实我们都穿着粉色衣服，过得很开心，谈论着山姆，谈论着一些积极的事情，并因此凝聚在一起。所以那真的是一个美好的时刻。
Where did you guys walk in London? That's 200 kilometers. No, so we walked from where I grew up in Kent, sort of mid-Kent all the way to London, which actually isn't 200 kilometres, but we were. like it was near enough 200 kilometers it was about 170 so we were like let's just add 30 and round it up classic add 30 so it's yeah it was 200 kilometers over 10 days um in September 2018 and it was it was that it was that was the only ever did it to raise a bit of money and then before I went to uni um and that was the walk really that was the event that I went I really want to do this for the rest of my life like I really saw the impact that you can have on other people's lives by having
你们在伦敦哪里徒步的？那可是200公里。不，我们从我长大的肯特郡出发，也就是肯特郡中部一直走到伦敦，这其实没有200公里，但我们……就像差不多有200公里，大约是170公里，所以我们就想，干脆加30公里凑个整吧。典型的加30公里。所以是的，那是2018年9月，历时10天完成了200公里的徒步，嗯，就是这样。那是唯一一次为了筹集一点资金而这样做，当时是在我上大学之前，那是一次真正的徒步，那是我意识到“我真的想在余生中做这件事”的活动，我真正看到了通过以下方式对他人生活产生的影响：
some of those some of the people that came on that walk you know went to spoke to their family about their things that were going on their life for the first time ever you know to be able to be the one to make someone feel comfortable enough to have those conversations and know how important that is I just yeah you can't not help someone make that step and not want to then keep helping other people make that step and get the right support. So it was really that was the formation for everything that came since. Wow. Well, this is a great segue. It is. Into Reasons to stay. Yeah. Which is, when did you launch this project? January. January. Four months ago, three months ago. That's- Don't. It's just huge. That is amazing. Because it has touched so many lives
参加那次徒步的一些人，你知道的，生平第一次和家人谈论了他们生活中发生的事情。你知道的，能够成为那个让某人感到足够舒适去进行这些对话、并深知其重要性的人，我只是，是的，你无法不帮助别人迈出那一步，然后不想继续帮助其他人迈出那一步并获得正确的支持。所以这确实是后来一切事物形成的基石。哇。嗯，这是一个很好的过渡。确实。关于“留下的理由”。是的。那是，你是什么时候推出这个项目的？一月。一月。四个月前，三个月前。那是——别这样。这规模太宏大了。这太棒了。因为它触动了那么多人的生活，
so quickly. Do you want to talk about it? I would love to talk about it. Talk me about the idea behind it. So I've worked in this space for eight years. I've spoken to more people that have felt suicidal or looked after someone that's suicidal than I can count. I mean, so many people. And the one thing I've realized with mental health is that unlike other social issues, it's very difficult for the general public to feel like they're practically involved in helping. So with climate change, you can recycle more. You can take public transport or ride a bike.
而且速度如此之快。你想聊聊它吗？我很乐意聊聊。跟我讲讲背后的想法吧。我从事这个领域已经八年了。我交谈过感觉有自杀倾向或照顾过有自杀倾向的人数不胜数。我的意思是，有太多太多人了。我关于心理健康意识到的唯一一件事是，与其他社会问题不同，广大公众很难觉得他们能切实参与到帮助中来。比如应对气候变化，你可以多回收利用。你可以乘坐公共交通工具或骑自行车，
and you can feel like you're practically involved in the solution. With mental health, unless you're a clinical professional or involved some way clinically, it's very difficult for you to actually help. And I've always thought that it would be good to find a way to connect the millions and millions and millions of people around the world that care about this issue and want to help with the millions or billions of people that need to be cared for. So that's the first point. Then the second point is the human race has a lot of problems, right? And it's difficult to feel good about us sometimes, especially in the world.
并且你可以觉得自己切实参与到了解决方案中。而在心理健康方面，除非你是临床专业人士或以某种方式参与临床工作，否则你很难真正提供帮助。我一直认为，如果能找到一种方法，将全世界数以千万计、甚至数以亿计关心这个议题并希望提供帮助的人，与数以百万或十亿计需要关怀的人联系起来，那该多好。这是第一点。然后第二点是，人类社会有很多问题，对吧？有时候很难对我们自己感觉良好，尤其是在当今世界。
It's a bit of a understatement. Yeah, right. But the one thing that I think is absolutely phenomenal about us as a species is that when there is a catastrophe, people that don't know each other will drop everything and run to help. And I think that is so remarkable and amazing. It's this instinct to just help strangers. that we all, most of us have, which I think is just incredible. And I think it's the most amazing thing about being a human being
这话说得有点保守了。是的，对吧。但我觉得作为物种，我们最不可思议的一点是，当发生灾难时，素不相识的人会放下一切，跑去帮忙。我认为这太非凡、太神奇了。这种去帮助陌生人的本能，我们所有人、我们大多数人都有，我觉得这简直不可思议。我认为作为人类最了不起的事情，
is that you can feel such deep empathy for someone you don't know. We always say that about elephants and then forget that actually we are, we do the same thing. And so those two things sort of came together and I was like, well, we've got a problem with suicide. We've got a lot of people that want to help. How can you let strangers help in a way that's clinically, safe and that's where reasons to stay came from. So essentially anyone in the world can write a letter
就是你能对一个不认识的人产生如此深切的同情。我们总是对大象这么说，却忘了其实我们也是这样的，我们也会做同样的事。所以这两点结合到了一起，我就想，好吧，我们有自杀的问题。我们有很多人想要帮忙。你如何能让陌生人以一种临床安全的方式提供帮助呢？这就是“留下的理由”（Reasons to Stay）的由来。所以本质上，世界上任何人都可以写一封信
on the site. That then goes to our clinical moderation team. They make sure everything's safe, publish it, and then anyone can go on and read one of these letters and have it delivered to them. And that was the idea. And I'd launched it this year in January on the 21st of January, which is the anniversary of Sam's death because that was my good thing that day. That's a, that's a way's a bad day. So I was like, you know, you need a hefty good thing to get through that day. A major one. But you need a big good thing. A million people will hear about this thing.
发在网站上。然后这会交到我们的临床审核团队手中。他们确保一切安全，将其发布，接着任何人都可以上去阅读这些信件并将其发送给自己。这就是当时的想法。我在今年1月21日推出了它，1月21日是山姆去世的周年纪念日，因为那是那天我做的一件好事。那是，那是糟糕的一天。所以我当时想，你知道的，你需要一件厚重的好事来度过那一天。一件大事。但你需要一件重大的好事。数百万人会听到这件事。
Yeah. And so, yeah, I launched that for no reason other than I thought it was a good idea. And I had very little expectation. It was a project that I wanted to work on in behind the scenes and sort of just really love to grow. I thought we'd maybe send 100 letters that week and we sent 33,000. And then by mid-February, we'd sent a million. And as of now, we've sent 3.6 million letters to people in 180 countries in, what's that, just over three months? It's been, we've reached 70 million people on social media with this project.
是的。所以，是的，我推出这个项目没有别的理由，只是觉得这是一个好主意。而且我当时抱有的期望很低。这只是一个我想在幕后进行并希望能真正发展壮大的项目。我以为我们那周大概会发出100封信，结果我们发出了33,000封。到了2月中旬，我们已经发出了100万封。截至目前，我们在3个多月的时间里，向180个国家的人们发送了360万封信，这算是什么？这算是在社交媒体上通过这个项目触及了7000万人。
It's just been like beyond anything I could possibly imagine. And I guess it goes to show that instinct of millions of people. people want to help was absolutely true. And it just, it worked. Oh my God. You guys gave me chills. That is the coolest, coolest story I've probably ever heard on the podcast. Oh, bless you. It's so amazing. It's been pretty incredible to see unfold in front of me. Yeah. And at every moment, particularly in those early days where it was so intense, you know, all the milestones just felt massive. Yeah. The first 100,000 was huge. then it was a million and then it has most people that if you know me will know me for a video
这简直超出了我所能想象的极限。我想这也证明了数以百万计的人想要帮忙的本能绝对是真的。而且它真的奏效了。天哪。你们让我起鸡皮疙瘩了。这可能是我在播客听过最酷、最酷的故事了。哦，谢谢你。这太棒了。看着它在我眼前展开，感觉真的相当不可思议。是的。在每一个时刻，尤其是在那些早期非常激烈的日子里，你知道，所有的里程碑都让人觉得意义重大。是的。前十万封是个巨大的数字，
I posted when I when I first heard that it helped someone yeah um and my reaction to what that meant to me um when I found out that someone had you know very literally survived because they written a letter um you know all those moments just were just it was just it was I feel every day I watched it climb to just enormous numbers and it was just, I was pinching myself constantly. What are you going to do for 10 million? I've got no idea, party. 200 km walk. That was the right answer.
然后是一百万封，然后大多数认识我的人如果了解我，都会知道我因为一个视频而认识我，那是我第一次听到它帮助了某人时发布的视频，是的，以及当我发现有人确实通过写信字面意义上地活了下来时，我对这件事对我意味着什么的反应……你知道，所有这些时刻，都只是……我每天看着它攀升到惊人的数字，我简直在不停地掐自己，看是不是在做梦。你打算在达到1000万封信的时候做什么？我完全不知道，开个派对吧。200公里徒步。那是正确的答案。
10 million. And you know what? It's absolutely mad is that will happen. I was going to say. It will happen this year. I think it will happen soon. Very soon. So it's, you know, it's, which is extraordinary, but it's also just such a nice reminder that, like,
1000万封。你知道吗？绝对疯狂的是，这真的会发生。我正想说呢。这今年就会发生。我觉得很快就会发生。非常快。所以，你知道的，这很不寻常，但这也是一个非常美好的提醒，那就是——
it's so bad what this is what's happening. Yeah. But at the end of the day, like, there are always reasons to stay, but there are always reasons to feel positive about the world. And you don't have to feel suicidal to benefit from reasons to stay the site. I go on that. You read a letter and you feel better about yourself and the world and this human race that we all are a part of. You just cannot go on that website and not feel better about the state of the world and who you are and your part in it. And I just think that's so wonderful just because, you know, I have, I do have this just love of people and what we can do for each other.
这情况虽然很糟糕，发生的事情很糟糕。是的。但归根结底，像，总是有留下来的理由，总是有理由对世界感到乐观。而且你不一定非得有自杀倾向才能从“留下的理由”这个网站中受益。我也会上去看。你读了一封信，然后你对自己、对世界、对我们大家都是其中一部分的这个人类群体感觉更好了。你不可能浏览那个网站却不为这个世界的现状、为你自己以及你在其中的角色感到一丝慰藉。我只是觉得这太美妙了，因为，你知道的，我确实对人类以及我们能为彼此做的事情抱有一种纯粹的爱。
And it just is such an amazing. And I had no idea this is going to be like this. I really genuinely put, you know, I put thought into it, but I didn't put this much thought into it. And to see what it's become and see how much it means to people. It's been very, very, very special. Yeah. We got to do. We. 10 million. Well, we'll come back for 10 million. Someone. We need to, the population of the world needs to give you a huge thank you for that. Oh, thank you. Listen, and you're there for heart-wrenching knockouts. The world's biggest stage.
这真的是太惊人了。我完全不知道事情会变成这样。我确实投入了心思，但我没投入这么多的心思。看到它变成了现在的样子，看到它对人们有多么重要，这真的非常、非常、非常特别。是的。我们得做点什么。我们。1000万。好吧，等达到1000万时我们会回来的。有人。我们需要，世界各族人民都需要为此向你致以诚挚的谢意。哦，谢谢。听着，你将迎接扣人心弦的对决。世界最大的舞台。
And breathtaking triumph. In 2026 FIFA World Cup, the knockout stage. Every match, every moment. Listen on TSN radio. Join the globe on the road to the July 19th final. 2026 FIFA World Cup. Stream it all live on TSN Radio. Available on IHeart Radio.
以及惊心动魄的胜利。2026年国际足联世界杯，淘汰赛阶段。每一场比赛，每一个时刻。请收听TSN电台。加入通往7月19日决赛的世界狂欢。2026年国际足联世界杯。在TSN电台收听所有赛事的现场直播。可在IHeart Radio上收听。
Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Okay, if you know me, you know this. I'm always searching for inspiration, for support, and useful tools to help maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover all of that together. We're going to have these meaningful conversations. with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges that she never saw coming.
嘿，我是霍达·柯特比（Hoda Kotb），播客《乔治·柯特比的快乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）的主持人。听着，如果你了解我，你就知道这一点。我一直在寻找灵感、支持和有用的工具来帮助实现最大程度的快乐。所以这个我们将一起探索这一切的播客。我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行这些有意义的对话。比如女演员奥利维娅·芒恩（Olivia Munn）分享了她是如何克服她从未预料到的严峻健康挑战的。
I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Olympic champ Sean Johnson revealed why she had no choice but to be a gymnast. There was something about gymnastics that was intoxicating to me. It's given me a belief that we would have. We all have one of those treasures inside of us.
我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌，那更加困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。奥运冠军肖恩·约翰逊（Shawn Johnson）透露了她为什么别无选择只能成为一名体操运动员。体操身上有一种东西让我深深着迷。它给了我一种信念，那就是我们将会拥有。我们每个人内心都藏着其中一件宝藏。
We just have to find it. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Mungesha Together, and I'm back with a new season of the podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I'm diving into a rabbit hole of peptides, organoids, blood boys, blue zones, and brain replacement to try to understand what this longevity obsession is all about. And what it really means to live forever for all of us. I learned about some rad science. I can make a brain for you, and then we can test what draw is the best for your brain, as opposed to his brain. Here's some hard truths.
我们只需要找到它。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听霍达·柯特比的《快乐101》。我是蒙格沙·托杰（Mungesha Together），我带着新一季的播客《天际线大道》（Skyline Drive）回归了。这一次，我将深入探讨多肽、类器官、血液青年、蓝色地带和大脑替代的兔子洞，试图理解这种长寿执念到底是怎么回事。以及对于我们所有人来说，长寿的真正含义。我了解了一些很酷的科学。我可以为你制造一个大脑，然后我们可以测试哪种药对你的大脑最好，而不是对他的大脑最好。这里有一些残酷的真相。
I would expect Indians to age faster, but I did not expect it to be almost a four to five-year acceleration. And get myself into a world of trouble. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. Make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive
我本以为印度人的衰老速度会更快，但我没想到它会加速将近四到五年。并且让自己陷入了一场大麻烦。我想大概是开始“骨骼重塑”吧。那不管用。让它看起来更立体。他们说这管用。我不知道。请收听《天际线大道》
How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture,
《如何长寿》（How to Live Forever），可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Champs》播客中，我们将与文化中最热门的大咖对话，
like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got like so much more to do. Like Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now.
比如斯韦·李（Swae Lee）。你意识到自己有多传奇吗？我很感激。我经常看到，但我心想，天哪，我还有好多事要做。就像王子（Prince），他发了大约30张专辑。我们现在才发了大约五张。
That's the rate we got to be going. Yeah, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddy. I directed when the Nas's early videos. Which one? One love. Wow. Yes.
这就是我们前进的速度。是的，这态度真好。你还会听到来自行业传奇和嘻哈先锋的故事，比如法布·5·弗雷迪（Fab 5 Freddy）。我导演了纳斯（Nas）早期的几支音乐录影带。哪一个？《One love》。哇。是的。
I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. Nas was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff. And he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names, and the most unfiltered conversations.
我真的就是在昆斯布里奇（Queensbridge）他的公寓里拍摄的。他妈妈当时还在那个公寓里。纳斯才刚刚开始崭露头角。他老爸以前住在哈林区附近，离我很近。他爸爸把他引入了许多，你知道的，有意识的领域。并造就了一位年轻奇才。无论哪个时代，《Drink Champs》都会为你带来最大牌的人物和最无滤镜的对话。
Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America,
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect Podcast Network的《Drink Champs》。这里有一件本不该这么复杂的事情：移除种族主义者的雕像。这里还有一件本该容易得多、但事实并非如此的事情：在原地竖立一座新雕像。只要美国还存在种族政治，
there's going to be a politics of remembering the civil war. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Lee Boulevard, Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence.
就会存在关于如何纪念南北战争的政治。去学校的路上，我必须经过罗伯特·李大道；去杂货店，我必须经过杰斐逊·戴维斯公园路。如果你是一个历史学家，却漏掉了历史的一半，那你就没有做好你的工作。我是阿基拉·休斯（Akila Hughes），《反叛精神》（Rebel Spirit）第二季将深入探讨这两件事。斗争、政治、获胜的人，以及我在肯塔基州议会大厦增加一些真正值得占用墙面空间的物件的个人运动。我们不仅仅是我们的身体。我们包含着本质。
We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Let's segue. I imagine, and we were talking about this before we were recording, that sometimes it's hard to talk about mental health all the time. And that you're probably, you know, you're very much the mental health guy online.
我们包含着精神。你如何体现这一点？他们只是在火上浇油，而这团火正呈燎原之势。你会明白我的意思的。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。让我们转到下一个话题。我猜想，而且我们在录音前也讨论过，有时候一直谈论心理健康是很困难的。而且你可能，你知道的，你在网络上非常明确地就是那个“心理健康小哥”。
You know, you've done this incredible thing. I'm not going to give that up for anything. But in your personal life as well, I'm sure a lot of people are like, oh, this is Ben. If I have a problem, I can go to Ben. Strangers probably think that. Is that hard sometimes? Yeah, it's extremely hard. Yeah.
你知道的，你做了这件不可思议的事。我不会为了任何事放弃这个。但在你的个人生活中，我相信也有很多人会想，哦，这是本。如果我有问题，我可以去找本。陌生人大概也是这么想的。有时候这很难吗？是的，极其艰难。是的。
It's extremely, extremely hard because also I'm in this because I care so much. So it's very difficult not to feel like you have to always talk about it. And look, I'm going to do this for the rest of my life. but it's also really important for me to know when is work and when it's not and with social media especially recently it's been very very difficult to step away from that and have me because at the end of the day mine i'm ben for most of my life i haven't talked about this and i have a whole you know personality that's built on not having to talk about mental health every day and i think sometimes he needs to just enjoy and laugh and you know that
极其、极其艰难，因为我也是因为太在乎才会做这个。所以很难不去觉得自己必须一直谈论它。听着，我要在余生中一直做这件事。但对我来说，同样非常重要的是要知道什么时候是工作，什么时候不是。特别是最近在社交媒体上，要从那个身份中抽身出来做回真正的自己，变得非常非常困难。因为归根结底，我的大部分人生里我都是本，我并没有一直在谈论这个，我有一个完整的人格，它建立在不必每天都谈论心理健康的基础之上。而且我觉得有时候他需要去享受、去欢笑，并且你知道的，
there is lots of positive and fun moments in this journey. There are also lots of incredibly devastating, sad, hard work hours and bad things that happen. And I don't think it's healthy for anyone to be, you know, experiencing that all the time. You know, when reasons to stay went viral, I got 50,000 messages in one day. And it's just like on a level that you, it's just not normal to be, And most of those were incredibly sensitive information about what someone was going through. You know, when I was scrolling through, almost all of them were, this is why this matters to me, which is obviously incredible and so lovely that people feel like they can share it.
这段旅程中有许多积极和快乐的时刻。也有许多极其毁灭性的、悲伤的、辛苦的工作小时以及糟糕的事情发生。我不认为任何人一直经历这一切是健康的。你知道，当“留下的理由”病毒式传播时，我一天之内收到了50,000条消息。这种程度，你根本无法承受，这不正常。而且其中绝大多数都是关于某人正在经历的极其敏感的信息。你知道，当我滚动浏览时，几乎所有内容都是：这就是为什么这对我很重要，这显然是不可思议的，人们觉得他们可以分享，这真是太美好了。
But that, just reading that volume of really sometimes quite harrowing stories, like it takes a toll. And so, yeah, it's important for me to do this work. I love it. I'm never, I'm never not going to do it. But it's also, as I've done this more and more, you've got to work out how you do things that are not this. Yeah. And even, and it's funny because I also run. And I made the decision to start like running to raise money for mental health, right?
但仅仅是阅读那个数量的、有时相当痛苦的故事，确实会带来精神损耗。所以，是的，对我来说做这项工作很重要。我热爱它。我永远、永远不会放弃它。但这也是，随着我做得越来越多，你必须弄清楚如何去做一些不是这样的事情。是的。甚至，有趣的是，我也跑步。我决定开始跑步来为心理健康筹集资金，对吧？
And so I've done like marathons and ultramarathons to like talk about this. And I've realized, you know, I've realized after this year's, I don't want to do that. I don't think. I want to keep running separate from mental health and not raise money and sort of just literally just do it. it for fun for me because I think I was pouring too much of myself into this. So it's a balancing act. But sometimes you are desperate for a, no offense to this podcast. Sometimes you're desperate for a podcast that's not about mental. Oh, yeah. So you ask me about like, I don't know, what else? What's my other, what would be my mastermind? Oh, we've got questions for you. Oh, brilliant. This is, but I've got
所以我跑过马拉松和超级马拉松来谈论这个。我意识到，你知道的，今年之后我意识到，我不想再那样做了。我想我不想了。我想把跑步和心理健康分开，不再去筹集资金，就只是字面意思上地去跑。纯粹为了好玩而跑，因为我觉得我在这个上面倾注了太多的自我。所以这是一种平衡的艺术。但有时你会非常渴望一个——无意冒犯这个播客——有时你会非常渴望一个不谈论心理健康的播客。哦，是的。所以你问我关于，我不知道，还有什么？什么是我的另一个，我的拿手好戏是什么？哦，我们有关于你的问题。哦，太棒了。这是，不过我有
some fun ones. Oh, I'm sure, I'm sure. But you know what I mean? And it must be the same with you sometimes, where it's like obviously it's hugely important, but sometimes it's important to just remember that it's like one part of me. Yeah. And I also have my own mental health, which sometimes you forget. That's the hard part, I think, when people think of you as this person who has it all sorted out since you're talking about it openly and it's like, I'm still really trying to figure it out myself.
一些有趣的问题。哦，我确信，我确信。但你知道我的意思吗？对你来说有时一定也是这样，很明显这非常重要，但有时候重要的是要记住这只是我的一部分。是的。而且我也有我自己的心理健康问题，有时候你也会忘记这一点。我认为这才是最难的部分，当人们认为你是一个已经把一切都搞定的人，因为你公开谈论它，而事实是：“我自己其实也还在努力弄清楚这一切。”
I get that a lot when I like, and it was interesting. Like it's, it is not a regular problem to have. No. It's not like, oh, too many people trust me. Yeah. You know, oh, you know, I just, I'm doing too good a job at helping people. But it is, like, I definitely have a similar experience where sometimes I've got to not talk about psychology. And it's hard to, like, sometimes friends will come to you and be like, and you want to be there for them. And that sometimes means being less present online so that you have the, the resources to show up where it really matters. Yeah, for sure, for sure. And it's, it's just about trying to. protect yourself at the end of the day. We're the difficult topic and this goes for, and I'm very lucky, obviously, that I've been doing this a long time, so I know a lot of people that work in a similar area and not just mental health campaigning,
当我看到，这很有趣。这确实不是一个寻常的问题。不。这不像是什么“哦，太多人信任我了”。是的。你知道的，“哦，你知道，我只是在帮助人方面做得太好了。”但这确实是，我绝对有过类似的经历，有时我必须不去谈论心理学。而且很难，比如有时候朋友会来找你，而你想成为他们的精神支柱。这意味着有时候需要在网上减少露面，这样你才有精力和资源去出现在真正重要的地方。是的，肯定的，肯定的。归根结底，这只是关于如何保护你自己。这是一个艰难的话题，不仅适用于我，我很幸运，显然我已经做这件事很久了，所以我认识很多在类似领域工作的人，不仅是心理健康活动人士，
but sort of loads of different areas of social issues, which are all difficult to experience, right, and to work in. So I've sort of learned a lot from them, and we support each other, right, because no one can talk about bad things all the time, Which actually, in fairness is one of the reasons that I wanted to start reasons to stay. Because in my work, you talk a lot about bad things. I do a lot of policy work.
还有许多不同领域的社会议题，所有这些经历起来都很困难，对吧，在其中工作也很艰难。所以我从他们身上学到了很多，我们互相支持，对吧，因为没有人能够一直谈论糟糕的事情，说实话，这也正是我想要发起“留下的理由”的原因之一。因为在我的工作中，你经常谈论糟糕的事情。我做了很多政策方面的工作。
I do a lot of work with data and with mental health in parliament. And you're never talking about it because things are going well. That's a very good point. And I think for me, I'm not like that. I'm always been a glass half full fun. I like fun. I like optimism. And so I, reason to stay came about because I was desperate to do something fun and positive and like something that's a good thing to talk about. And reason state is such a good thing to talk about. So it's like I, that was part of it as well, which is that I needed a way of doing something that was positive rather than what it was before, which was constantly talking about. You know, for a long time I was working on a campaign that was trying to improve. prove negligence laws. I'm like, negligence is never a conversation that is ever positive. Like, no positive thing ever leads to a negligence conversation. Yeah. So it's like, that's basically
我做了很多关于数据和议会心理健康的工作。你谈论它绝不是因为事情进展顺利。这是一个非常好的观点。我觉得对我来说，我不是那样的人。我一直都是个乐天派，喜欢有趣的事物。我喜欢快乐，我喜欢乐观。所以，“留下的理由”的诞生是因为我渴望做一些有趣、积极的事情，做一些谈论起来感觉很好的事情。而“留下的理由”是一个多么棒的话题啊。所以这就像我，这也是其中的一部分，也就是说我需要找到一种方法来做一些积极的事情，而不是像以前那样，一直在谈论。你知道，很长一段时间里，我一直在参与一个旨在改善过失法的运动。我想，过失永远不会是一个积极的对话。没有任何积极的事情会引发出过失的对话。是的。所以这就是，基本上
sums up sort of what the conversations I was happening. They were always about death and failure and negligence. And you're like, that is not, that is not particularly upbeat. It's very, very important, but you need, you need the balance. Yeah. And now you found it. I do. And probably like one of the reasons why you, like, you as an optimistic person, like this can only come from the brain of an optimistic person. Do you know what I mean? Yeah, it's a good point. So it's kind of like you feel like you found the way that,
总结了我当时进行的对话类型。它们总是关于死亡、失败和过失。你会想，那可真是一点都不轻快。虽然非常、非常重要，但你需要平衡。是的。现在你找到了。是的。这大概也就是为什么你，作为一个乐观的人，这只能出自一个乐观之人的大脑。你知道我的意思吗？是的，说得好。所以这感觉就像你找到了那种方法，
and just shows how many people were hungering for somebody to be like, can we talk about mental health in a way that isn't? It's hard, right? It's to find a positive spin and not that we should, but just in a way that it's proactive and positive and meaningful. Positive without being invalidating as well. Yeah, perfect way I say it. Because you can be positive about this, but come across like you're just quite making fun of someone or belittling something.
这恰恰表明有多少人在渴望有人能站出来说：“我们能不能用一种不那么……的方式来谈论心理健康？”这很难，对吧？去寻找一个积极的切入点，并不是说我们必须这样做，而是以一种积极、主动且有意义的方式。在不否认他人感受的前提下保持积极。是的，我完全赞同。因为你可以在这上面保持积极，但给人的感觉却像是在取笑某人或贬低某事。
But this is positive in a way of like, it's really awesome that we can do something for each other. And you know what? If you go on there and write a letter, you'll feel good about yourself and you'll feel like you're part of the thing. And it'll be just everything about it. It's just phenomenally positive from every perspective. And that's awesome to be part of it. of. It's just hope. Like that's suchly, I'm like, I was trying to think it's like it's not optimistic. It's not probably. It's just hopeful. Well, that is, at the end of the day, that is the reason to stay, right?
但这里的积极在于：我们能够为彼此做些事情，这真的很棒。你知道吗？如果你去那里写一封信，你会对自己感觉良好，你会觉得自己是这个集体的一部分。这里的一切，从每个角度来看都是惊人的积极。能成为其中的一部分真是太棒了。这就是希望。就像那是如此纯粹的，我想，我一直在想，这其实不是乐观。这可能不是乐观。这只是充满希望。好吧，归根结底，这就是留下的理由，对吧？
The reason to stay only exists when there's hope. And when there's no hope, then there's no reason to stay. So all we're trying to do in that moment is give someone something, some little tiny little spark of hope to get them through that moment. And that for a lot of people is what that letter represents. And I just think that, you know, I know that in the three and a half million people that have read a letter, I know that so many of them really feel connected to that person that's written a letter. And it's almost like, and I knew this when I was designing actually, that there's was something I wanted people to feel. It's almost like somewhere there is.
只有当存在希望时，留下的理由才存在。而当没有希望时，也就没有理由留下了。所以我们在那个时刻所做的一切，就是给某人一些东西，一点点微小的希望火花，来帮助他们度过那个时刻。对许多人来说，这就是那封信所代表的意义。我只是觉得，我知道在那350万读过信的人中，我知道他们中有很多人真的与那个写信的人产生了连接。这几乎就像是，我在设计时就知道这一点，这是我想让人们感受到的东西。这几乎就像在某个地方，有一个
Your letter writer, they're real, they're out there. And it's like you've got this guardian angel, this person that you don't know and will never meet, that's just sort of cheering you on. And I just think there's something quite beautiful in that being your reason to stay when everything else in your life is absolute chaos and you've got no hope, you've got that person who's written your letter because they care.
给你写信的人，他们是真实的，他们就在那里。就像你拥有了一个守护天使，一个你不认识也永远不会见面的人，正在为你加油打气。我觉得当生活中的一切都绝对是一团糟、你毫无希望时，能把这个作为你留下的理由，里面有一种非常美丽的东西，那就是你拥有那个写信的人，因为他们在乎你。
And if you have no other reason to stay, they can be that reason. And I think that is a very, very, very powerful thing to give someone that maybe has nothing or feels like they have nothing. And also just a sense of like, Oh, somebody cares about me. Yeah.
如果你没有其他留下的理由，他们就可以成为那个理由。我认为这对于一个可能一无所有或觉得自己一无所有的人来说，是非常、非常、非常强大的东西。并且也带有一种感觉，比如：“哦，有人在乎我。”是的。
Like, somebody is thinking about me. Yeah. And that's, like, so beautiful. Okay, let's finish up with a couple questions. So we're going to talk about your book in a second. Okay. But firstly, let's talk about some other things that you are beyond mental health. Yeah.
“有人在想我。”是的。这真的太美好了。好了，让我们用几个问题来结束。我们一会儿再聊你的书。好的。但首先，让我们聊聊除了心理健康之外的其他事情。是的。
So I've got some rapid-fire questions. Okay, here we go. Before we're going to finish with two final questions. We'll let you have your water. We've been depriving you of that. I feel like I need to prepare for these. Well, you do. They're very important.
所以我有一些快问快答的问题。好的，我们开始吧。在结束时会有最后两个问题。我们先让你喝口水。我们一直剥夺你这个权利了。我觉得我需要为这些问题做点准备。嗯，确实需要。它们非常重要。
Okay. Are you ready? Okay, favourite song at the moment? Or anything by Noah Khan. What's the new album's absolutely fantastic? View Between Villages, that was the old album, wasn't it? But that is probably my favourite. And it's also the tune I put over my huge viral reel,
好吧。准备好了吗？好的，目前最喜欢的歌？诺亚·卡恩（Noah Khan）的任何歌。那张新专辑绝对太棒了。《村庄之间的风景》（View Between Villages），那是上一张专辑里的，对吧？但那可能是我最喜欢的。这也是我放在那个播放量破千万的爆款短视频里的曲子，
so it almost feels like a very fitting song for that. Did he see the reel? No, I don't think so. Maybe secretly. I feel like he secretly did. Please, Noah. Noah can't. And also, he does amazing work for mental health.
所以感觉它非常契合那段视频。他看到那个视频了吗？没有，我不这么认为。也许偷偷看过了。我觉得他肯定是偷偷看了。求你了，诺亚。诺亚·卡恩。而且他为心理健康做了了不起的工作。
It does. He's a dream guest for me. Yeah. He's awesome. He's no album's great. If I get his number, I'll send it to you. Oh, do. Yeah. Maybe he's the 10 million celebration. Noah Khan. I love how we're putting it out there. Yeah, a few between villages. Great. Okay. Subway order. Subway order, mebo marinar. Cheese and toasted. Cheese and toast. What kind of bread? Hearted Italian.
确实如此。他是我梦寐以求的嘉宾。是的。他太棒了。他的新专辑很棒。如果我拿到他的号码，我发给你。哦，请务必发给我。好。也许可以作为1000万庆祝活动的嘉宾。诺亚·卡恩。我喜欢我们这样隔空喊话。是的，《村庄之间的风景》。太棒了。好的。赛百味点单。赛百味点单，美式肋排堡（Meatball Marinara）。加芝士并烤一下。加芝士并烤一下。什么面包？心形意大利面包。
Oh, classic. The best. Veg? So, yeah, lettuce, pickles, jalapinos. And then. And weirdly, not ranch. Why has it left me? It's the sort of spicy mayo thing. Chipotle mayo. Weird. I knew it.
哦，经典。最好的。蔬菜？嗯，生菜、酸黄瓜、墨西哥辣椒。然后。奇怪的是，不是牧场酱。怎么叫不出来了？就是那种有点辣的蛋黄酱。奇波雷美乃滋（Chipotle mayo）。真奇怪。我就知道。
Once you're in with your selection, you can't really change, can you? No, I was talking about this is my friend. Yeah, I was thinking that. I was like, it's quite a spicy sandwich as well. It's quite difficult to eat of your not. Yeah. No olives in it, though. No, no, no.
一旦你选定了选项，你就不能真的改变了，对吧？对，我当时正跟我朋友聊这个。是的，我也这么想。我觉得这其实也是个挺辣的三明治。如果你不习惯的话，其实挺难吃的。不过里面没有橄榄。不，不，不。
Interesting. Okay, who's your face? This is real hard-healing. Yeah, I like this. Who's your favorite Nepo baby? Wow. Nepo baby. Roman Kemp, he's big up the mental health topic. I know we're trying to get away from mental health, but he does do amazing work. I don't know who that is. Roman Kemp in the UK, Capital Breakfast used to be Capital Breakfast. He does Vodafone adverts. Oh my, okay. Well, I'm not from the UK, so I need to do my research.
有意思。好吧，谁是你的最爱？这真是个灵魂拷问。是的，我喜欢这个。你最喜欢的“星二代”（Nepo baby）是谁？哇。“星二代”。罗曼·坎普（Roman Kemp），他在大力推广心理健康话题。我知道我们正试图远离心理健康，但他确实做了了不起的工作。我不知道那是谁。罗曼·坎普在英国，以前是Capital Breakfast的电台主播。他拍过沃达丰（Vodafone）的广告。噢，好吧。嗯，我不是英国人，所以我得去做做功课。
Roman Kemp in the UK. Internationally, his dad was Martin Kemp, who's in a band. Well, of course I know who that is, yeah. No clue. What's the band? The band. Oh, now you put me on the quote. I have no idea. Okay.
英国的罗曼·坎普。国际上，他爸爸是马丁·坎普（Martin Kemp），在一个乐队里。好吧，我当然知道那是谁，是的。毫无头绪。什么乐队？那个乐队。哦，现在你把我问住了。我完全不知道。好吧。
No offense to Martin Camp. I'm going to go search. It's okay. I'll Wikipedia. Favorite royal family member. Ooh, Prince William. Yeah. Yeah, strong.
无意冒犯马丁·坎普。我要去搜一下。没关系。我会去维基百科查的。最喜欢的皇室成员。哦，威廉王子。是的。是的，很坚定的选择。
Again, like, come on. Big up the mental health. My friend met him. Yeah. And he was, and him and Princess Kate? Princess Kate, is that her name? Yeah, she's princess. Yeah.
再次说明，拜托。大力支持心理健康。我朋友见过他。是的。他和凯特王妃？凯特王妃，是叫这个名字吗？是的，她是王妃。是的。
And she was like, that's like every, I feel like Australians come to the UK and are like, so I need to meet a royal. They are lovely. Yeah. They do some amazing work. And actually I work quite closely with the Kensington Palace team. And like, obviously he's very committed to like mental health. He really is. Does a really good job.
她就像是，我觉得澳大利亚人来到英国都会想：“我得去见见皇室成员。”他们真的很可爱。是的。他们做了很多了不起的工作。实际上，我和肯辛顿宫的团队合作得相当紧密。而且很显然，他对心理健康非常坚定。他真的很投入。做得非常出色。
On like a very serious level. Yeah. And actually, when I've met him previously talking about some of the stuff that we're doing, he's always, he's always quite, in a good way, quite like, it gives you challenge. about stuff that you can do. So it's like he's not just briefed to know a little bit enough to get through a conversation. He really knows his stuff, which I've always thought was a good sign of someone that actually cares rather than just sort of repeating what he was told. Yeah, I really like that.
在一个非常严肃的层面上。是的。而且事实上，我以前见他谈论我们正在做的一些事情时，他总是，用一种很好的方式，相当具有建设性，他会给你提出挑战，关于你能做的事情。所以他不仅仅是 briefings（做简报）了解一点皮毛来应付对话。他是真的懂行，我一直认为这是一个真正关心此事的人的标志，而不是仅仅重复别人告诉他的话。是的，我真的很喜欢这一点。
He really knows his stuff when it comes to mental health. And that's a good lesson for like people like us as well to be like, okay, when we like engage other people, like all the people that we work with higher up as well, like how do we engage them? Like it's actually good to push back a little bit sometimes. Yeah, a bit of challenge is always a good thing. With the right tone, like we're coming alongside and helping trying to understand what you could do more of. Yeah. But yeah, I think he's always been, yeah, good for that.
他在心理健康方面真的很懂。这对我们这样的人来说也是一个很好的借鉴，就是说，好吧，当我们接触其他人时，比如我们共事的那些高层管理人员，我们该如何与他们沟通呢？其实有时候适当反驳一下是挺好的。对，带有一点挑战性总归是件好事。用对语气，就像我们是在一旁协助，努力去理解你能做更多什么。对。不过对，我觉得他在这方面一直都挺厉害的。
I love that you are a close, perhaps close friend of Prince William. So now I can take it off my list. No, Prince William, no. And Roman camp. If they're free for the 10 million body. Let's get them on a round table. Come on. Okay.
我很喜欢你是威廉王子的密友，也许是挚友。所以我现在可以把它从我的名单上划掉了。不，威廉王子，没有。还有罗曼（Roman）营地。如果他们有空参加这个千万身家的聚会。咱们把他们请到圆桌上来吧。来吧。好的。
First job. First job, a bar, in a bar. In a pub? Yeah, in a pub. What was the pub called? Um, oh, that's a really, the milk house. The milk house. See, I thought it was going to be like his lord's head or something.
第一份工作。第一份工作，在酒吧，在一家酒吧里。在一家酒馆里？对，在一家酒馆。那家酒馆叫什么名字？嗯，哦，那名字很特别，叫“牛奶屋”（The milk house）。“牛奶屋”。你看，我本来以为会叫什么“勋爵头”之类名字呢。
They have some weird names around here. They do. We love a weird name. I know. And the amount of them that are called like the Queens something. Yeah. The Queen's head. Yeah.
他们那附近有些名字挺古怪的。确实。我们就喜欢古怪的名字。我知道。而且那些叫什么“女王什么”的店也太多了吧。对。“女王之首”（The Queen's head）。对。
There's some, what's the most popular on? White Hart. Yeah. Yeah. The Queen's wig. The Queens, I don't know. Well, you, well, I wasn't, I'm about to say where you lived. So I'm not going to do that.
有些，最受欢迎的是哪个？“白鹿”（White Hart）。对。对。“女王的假发”（The Queen's wig）。“女王”，我不知道。好吧，你，好吧，我本来不说你住哪里的。所以我才不说呢。
But I always found that place funny. Yes. Yeah, I agree. What's your biggest vice? Oh, slow walkers. You know, which is ironic because I was really late to this. Okay, but that's a pet peeve. What's a vice?
但我一直觉得那个地方挺搞笑的。是的。没错，我同意。你最大的坏习惯是什么？哦，走路慢的人。你知道的，这挺具有讽刺意味的，因为我来这里的时候可迟到了。好吧，但那只是个让人心烦的小习惯。什么才叫坏习惯？
Like, what's something that you do that you're like, I shouldn't do that. Oh, from me personally. That's a really good question. Oh, I love Coke Zero. You know, everyone tells you that it's Coke Zero worse than normal Coke? I have tons of Coke zero. You know that, oh, you just get through it. How much do you have to do? It's like your kind of Buono is my Coke zero. Well, my Coke Zero is also my Coke Zero. Oh, really? Yeah, I'm not going. I've, yeah, my doctor was like, you got to stop.
比如，你有什么事是觉得自己不该做，却还是会做的？哦，就我个人而言。这真是个好问题。哦，我超爱零度可乐（Coke Zero）。你知道的，每个人都对你说，零度可乐比普通可乐更糟糕吗？我喝了大量的零度可乐。你知道的，哦，你就是一直在喝。你得喝多少？这就像你的健乐多（Buono）一样，而我的就是零度可乐。哦，我的零度可乐也是我的零度可乐。哦，真的吗？对，我不会放弃。我，我的医生曾对我说，你得戒了。
Oh, really? She was like, it's bad for you, really bad for you. I know that's, I'm found, I found myself on forums, not forums at like midnight going, is Coke zero better than normal Coke? Or is it, is it the sugar that's bad? Or is it, is it Aspartame or something? Yeah, phenylin and all these artificial sweetness. Look away. I know. You could be. And coffee, to be fair, I have a lot of coffee, which I know is not very good for you.
哦，真的吗？她说这东西对你不好，真的对健康非常不好。我知道，我发现自己经常在半夜逛论坛，不是论坛，是那种深夜去搜：“零度可乐比普通可乐好吗？”或者，“到底是糖不好？还是阿斯巴甜之类的东西不好？”对，苯丙氨酸还有所有这些人工甜味剂。别看。我知道。你可能会。还有咖啡，说实话，我喝很多咖啡，我知道这对身体不太好。
I think coffee is not the worst vice. No, a nice little, nice bit. I think sometimes I go a little bit over the top. Because I do a lot of coffee meetings. Do you know when people like, oh, do you want to have coffee? I stack my coffees. So what happens is then you've got like five people you're meeting in the morning and you have a coffee. And I need to be better at going, I'm just going to have.
我觉得咖啡不算最坏的坏习惯。不，来上一杯不错的，感觉挺好。有时候我觉得自己有点过头了。因为我有很多咖啡会议。你知道当人们说，“哦，你想喝杯咖啡吗？”我把咖啡安排得满满当当。所以结果就是，早上你要见五个人，每个人都要喝一杯咖啡。我得改改这个习惯，告诉自己：“我只要喝……”
Hot chocolate. A Coke. I mean, actually, I'll have the throat zero, and it's 9 a.m. Yeah, exactly. Pour it up on the rocks, please. Or a hot chocolate, that's a great idea. But sometimes you feel like, this shouldn't be the case, but sometimes you feel that you can't order a hot chocolate because it's childish.
热巧克力。一杯可乐。其实，我要一杯零度可乐，而且现在是早上9点。对，没错。请给我加冰，谢谢。或者一杯热巧克力，这主意太棒了。但有时候你会觉得——虽然本不该如此——但有时候你会觉得你不能点热巧克力，因为那显得太孩子气了。
If I'm meeting like a really, look at me, I'm dressed like this. Imagine if I walked up and I was like, well, have a hot chocolate with marshmallows, please? Double mash, please. Yeah, I'm not sure that's great for my credibility. I think it's honestly better because you're like, I'm confident enough that I'm going to, like, look how I represent my ideals right now. True. because I'm a black Americano guy as well.
如果我要见一个非常——看看我，我穿成这样。想象一下，如果我走过去说：“请给我来一杯加棉花糖的热巧克力，好吗？”请加双份棉花糖，谢谢。是的，我不确定这对我的信誉是否有帮助。说实话，我觉得这样更好，因为你会想：“我有足够的自信去展示——比如看看我现在是怎么代表我的理念的。”确实如此。因为我也是个黑美式咖啡（black Americano）的忠实粉丝。
So that is a big shift. That's a big coffee. So you couldn't get further from a black Americano. Maybe a mocker. We'll get you somewhere in the middle. Give it a go. Give it a go, Ben. Okay, two more questions.
所以这是一个巨大的转变。那是一杯很浓的咖啡。所以你不可能找到比黑美式更远的东西了。也许是摩卡。我们带你找个折衷的办法。试试看吧。试一试，本。好的，还有两个问题。
You already said because Pet peeve was the next question. Slow walkers? Oh, Pet peeve, slow walkers. Yeah, I'm the same. Yeah. And people that walk in groups on small pavement. I live in London, right? We've got very small pavements in some of these places.
你刚才已经说过了，因为下一个问题就是让人心烦的小习惯。走路慢的人？哦，讨厌的小习惯，走路慢的人。对，我也是。还有在窄人行道上一群人并排走着的人。我住在伦敦，对吧？在某些地方，我们的人行道非常窄。
And it is people walk very slowly in lines. I don't know why they do that. I have to really hold it in. I do. It's my, I can get cranky. My girlfriend's the same. Really? When we're together walking and that happens, it's tough.
然后人们排成一排走得很慢。我不知道他们为什么要那样。我真的得极力克制自己。我真的会。这是我的毛病，我会变得很暴躁。我女朋友也一样。真的吗？当我们一起走路遇到这种情况时，太难熬了。
Have you gone by down Regents Canal recently? Yeah. Don't do it. Awful. I know. Soho. Pavements are only one person wide and you've got three people walking. Yeah.
你最近去过摄政运河（Regents Canal）那边吗？对。别去。太糟糕了。我知道。还有苏荷区（Soho）。人行道只容得下一个人通过，偏偏有三个人在走。对。
Holding hands. I know. And I've got to somewhere to go. Yeah. And they don't. They just tourists. Yeah. You enjoy.
手拉着手。我知道。而我还有地方要去。对。但他们没有。他们只是游客。对。祝你们玩得开心。
Yeah. It's great. Yeah. Favorite TV show? Favorite TV show. Oh, you know what? I loved MythBusters. Random one.
太棒了。对。最喜欢的电视节目？最喜欢的电视节目。哦，你知道吗？我超爱《流言终结者》（MythBusters）。一个挺随意的节目。
But that was so good. That is my childhood. Adam Savage and the other one. With the glasses. Yeah, I know. Is he still alive? No, you know, it was. He died?
但那个节目太棒了。那是我的童年。亚当·萨维奇（Adam Savage）和另一个人。戴眼镜那个。对，我知道。他还活着吗？不，你知道的，那是。他去世了？
No, they're both still alive. It was Grant who died. Oh, God. You know, there was the two and then there was the three. I was very sad. He was quite. actually, I think. It was maybe last year. Do you know they weren't friends?
不，他们俩都还活着。去世的是格兰特（Grant）。哦，天哪。你知道的，以前是两个人，后来变成了三个人。我当时很难过。其实他挺——我觉得。大概是去年吧。你知道他们其实不是朋友吗？
I know. They didn't get on. They didn't get on. You would never know. No, they were so good. What was your favorite myth? Favorite myth? There was one about a bullet curving. That was quite good when you shot it like that. That was quite good. I mean, all the explosions are great. God, it's a really good question. It's been a long time since I've watched any of them. Mine was that another bullet one was like getting shot underwater.
我知道。他们合不来。他们合不来。你绝对看不出来。不，他们太棒了。你最喜欢的流言是什么？最喜欢的流言？有一个关于子弹会拐弯的流言。当你那样开枪时，那个挺有意思的。那个挺不错的。我是说，所有的爆炸场面都很棒。天哪，真是个好问题。我好久没看他们的节目了。我最喜欢的另一个子弹相关的流言是在水下开枪。
Oh, that was a good one. Watch this episode get rated R now. Yeah, so true. In Methsters. Myth buses was great. And then you can't go wrong with a bit of Spongebob. That's, I did not think you were going to say that. I thought you had maybe like a Parks and Rec Brooklyn 9-9 guy. No, neither.
哦，那个挺有意思的。看着吧，这集现在要被评为限制级了。对，确实如此。《流言终结者》。《流言终结者》太棒了。然后看点《海绵宝宝》也绝对不会出错。那是，我没想到你会这么说。我还以为你会喜欢《公园与游憩》（Parks and Rec）或《神烦警探》（Brooklyn 9-9）呢。不，都不是。
I've not watched either of those shows. I'm not really good for TV. My girlfriend's big, like her family is very big on films and TV shows. And I'm sort of, I get outed every time. They're like, oh, have you not seen that? And you should definitely have seen that. When somebody's like, you haven't seen parks and recreation? No.
这两个节目我都没看过。我真的不太适合看电视。我女朋友的家庭，她的家人非常喜欢电影和电视节目。而我属于那种每一次都会露馅的人。他们会说：“哦，你没看过那个吗？你绝对应该看过那个。”当有人说：“你没看过《公园与游憩》？”不。
And you're like, no. That was about to be me, sir. An IHart Radio experience. Weekend gold tickets to Ilsoniq. One, two, three. With Dom Dahlah, Chris Lakin friends, Woolly, Deadmouse, above and beyond, sub-focus, and more.
然后你说：“没有。”我刚才差点就要那么说了，先生。一个 iHeart Radio 体验活动。伊尔索尼克音乐节（Ilsoniq）周末黄金门票。一，二，三。与多姆·达拉（Dom Dahlah）、克里斯·莱金（Chris Lakin）及朋友们，伍利（Woolly）、死鼠（Deadmau5）、上天入地（Above and Beyond）、萨布福克斯（Sub Focus）等一起。
With flights from Porter Airlines, three nights at Residence in downtown Montreal, and $1,000 cash. Enter for your chance to win at iHeartre Radio.ca. Ilsonique in Montreal, every day you enter, is another chance to win. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbby.
包含波特航空公司（Porter Airlines）的机票、蒙特利尔市中心Residence酒店三晚住宿，以及1000美元现金。登录 iHeartradio.ca 参与抽奖，赢取大奖。蒙特利尔伊尔索尼克音乐节，多参与一天，就多一次中奖机会。嘿，我是霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotb），播客《霍达的欢乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）的主持人。
Okay, if you know me, you know this. I'm always searching for inspiration, for support, and useful tools to help maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover all of that together. We're going to have these meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges, that she never saw coming. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer,
好吧，如果你了解我，你就会知道这一点。我一直在寻找灵感、支持和实用的工具，来帮助我们将快乐最大化。所以这个节目让我们能够一起探索这一切。我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行这些有意义的对话。就像当演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服从未预料到的严峻健康挑战时。我经历了乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，
and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Olympic champ Sean Johnson revealed why she had no choice but to be a gymnast. There was something about gymnastics that was intoxicating to me. It's given me a belief that we all have one of those treasures inside of us.
而那更加艰难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑症毫无准备。奥运冠军肖恩·约翰逊（Sean Johnson）透露了她为什么别无选择，只能成为一名体操运动员。体操身上有一种东西让我深深着迷。它让我坚信，我们每个人的内心深处都藏着这样一件宝物。
We just have to find it. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Mungesha Ticuiler, and I'm back with a new season of the podcast Skyline Drive. This time I'm diving into a rabbit hole of peptides, organoids, blood boys, blue zones, and brain replacement to try to understand what this longevity obsession is all about and what it really means to live forever, for all of us.
我们只需要去找到它。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方，收听《霍达的欢乐101》。我是孟盖莎·蒂奎勒（Mungesha Ticuiler），播客《天际线大道》（Skyline Drive）全新一季回归了。这一次，我将深入探讨肽、类器官、年轻血液、蓝色宝地和大脑替换的无底洞，试图理解这种长寿执念究竟是怎么回事，以及对我们所有人来说，长寿真正意味着什么。
I learned about some rad science. I can make a brain for you, and then we can test what drive. is the best for your brain, as opposed to his brain. Here's some hard truths. I would expect Indians to age faster, but I did not expect it to be almost a four to five year acceleration. And get myself into a world of trouble. I'd say probably start bone smashing.
我了解了一些很酷的科学。我可以为你制造一个大脑，然后我们可以测试哪种驱动方式最适合你的大脑，而不是他的大脑。以下是一些残酷的真相。我本以为印度人衰老得更快，但我没想到会加速近四到五年。并且让自己陷入了巨大的麻烦中。我大概会建议开始砸骨头。
That doesn't work. To make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever, on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Keith Giamanka seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly he became someone else,
那不管用。为了让轮廓看起来更立体。他们说管用。我不知道。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方，收听《天际线大道：如何长生不老》（Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever）。基思·贾曼卡（Keith Giamanka）看起来像个温文尔雅的郊区父亲，但暗地里他却变成了另一个人，
a master of disguise who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy, but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out. Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong or what that might look like? No. I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets.
一个开启犯罪狂潮的伪装大师。当时，这听起来像是一个疯狂的想法吗？听起来非常疯狂，但我当时感到如此绝望，以至于我觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。你有没有让自己去想过事情会怎样出错，或者那会是什么样子？没有。我不想去吸引那种负能量。我当时正努力吸引成功。每个家庭都有秘密。
But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man. on the iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are?
但是，当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜男人的样子。这将会永远改变我和我的家庭动态，因为我现实中先前的所有认知现在都成了谎言。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方，收听《深度卧底：顾家好男人》（Deep Cover the Family Man）。六月是黑人音乐月（Black Music Month），在《喝杯茶聊天》（Drink Champs）播客中，我们正在与文化界最红的名字对话，比如斯韦·李（Sway Lee）。你意识到自己有多传奇吗？
I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now. Like, that's the rate we got to be going. Yeah, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fabrizzles. Five Freddy.
我很感激。我会看到这些，但我会想：“天哪，我还有——还有那么多事要做。”就像普林斯（Prince）那样，他发了大概30张专辑。我们现在才发了大概五张。这就是我们必须前进的步伐。对，这是一个好态度。你还会听到来自行业传奇和嘻哈先锋的故事，比如法比里齐尔斯。五代弗雷迪（Fab 5 Freddy）。
I directed when the Nas' early videos. Which one? One love. Wow. I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge.
我执导了纳斯（Nas）早期的音乐录影带之一。哪一个？《一生爱一人》（One love）。哇。我真的在他在昆斯布里奇（Queensbridge）的公寓里拍摄的。
His moms were still up in that apartment. Nas was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem. His dad introduced him to a whole lot
他妈妈当时还住在那个公寓里。纳斯那时才刚开始崭露头角。他爸爸以前住在哈林区（Harlem）离我不远的地方。他爸爸向他介绍了大量
of, you know, conscious stuff, and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drink Chance brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams
你知道的，那些有意识形态的东西，并造就了一个年轻的天才。无论哪个时代，《喝杯茶聊天》都会为你带来最大牌的人物和最无滤镜的对话。收听《喝杯茶聊天》
from the Black Effect podcast network on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Okay, let's talk about your book. Man, my book. Look what he has right here. Oh, wow. It's so awesome to see in real life. What's it called for the people who aren't watching?
来自黑人效应播客网络（Black Effect podcast network），在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方。好了，我们来聊聊你的书。天哪，我的书。看看他手里拿的这个。哦，哇。在现实生活中看到它感觉太棒了。对于没有在看视频的人来说，它叫什么名字？
This is called Reasons 2. It's based on reasons to stay, but this is going to be filled with letters from real people for not just moments where you might need a reason to stay, but I just love the idea of people writing about grief. and anxiety and overthinking and depression. Like, I really want this book to be there for any moment. Whatever you're going through, you can open it and there'll be a letter from a real person, just like with reason to stay, but about a moment in your life.
这本书叫《理由2》（Reasons 2）。它是基于《活下去的理由》（reasons to stay）创作的，但这本书将收录来自真实人们的信件，不仅是为了那些你可能需要一个活下去的理由的时刻，而且我就是喜欢人们书写悲伤、
Wow. And this one is currently completely empty. I was going to say, can you read this one? This is my inspiration to actually get the work done and fill it. But yeah, no, this is sort of, it's lovely to be able to actually see this. But these pages are eventually going to be filled with real people's letters. I just think that's going to be so beautiful.
焦虑、过度思考和抑郁这个概念。真的，我希望这本书能在任何时刻都陪伴着你。无论你经历着什么，你都可以翻开它，里面都会有一封来自真实之人的信，就像《活下去的理由》一样，但它是关于你生活中的某一个时刻。哇。而这本目前完全是空的。我正想说，你能读读这一本吗？这是我真正完成工作并把内容填满的灵感来源。但对，不，这有点——能够亲眼看到这个感觉太棒了。但这些页面最终将填满真实人们的信件。我只是觉得那会非常美丽。
Like just whatever you're going through, open it to a page and someone's written you a letter about the thing that you're going through. How beautiful. And it just gets to the heart of what reason to stay is about. Yeah. Are you going to write them all? No, these will be other people. Okay.
就像无论你正在经历什么，翻开一页，就会有人写信给你，谈论你正在经历的事情。多么美好。这正触及了《活下去的理由》的核心意义。是的。这些信全都是你写的吗？不，这些会是其他人的。好的。
So there'll be people that have submitted two reasons to stay. Okay. So we're taking basically the best letters from all these different topics and putting them in here. So, no, I'm not writing. I think I'm, the less I write in this, I think the better. I really want this to be exactly with like with reasons to stay where it's strangers. Yeah. Supporting strangers.
所以这些会是那些向《活下去的理由》投稿的人。好的。所以我们基本上会挑选所有这些不同主题中最棒的信件，然后把它们放进这里。所以，不，我没有在写。我觉得我——我在这本书里写得越少，我觉得可能越好。我真的希望这本书能和《活下去的理由》完全一样，是由陌生人。对。去支持陌生人。
And all of them will be real people. Oh my goodness. And so there will be a, there will be a situation where, you know, I'll have, I don't know how many letters we're choosing yet. 100, 150 real people that have really spent time writing. Oh, how special. The less I write in here, the better. because I just want to sort of curate this with people's words. And it's going to be anonymous as well.
而且所有这些人都会是真人。哦天哪。所以会有一种情况，你知道的，我会拥有——我还不知道我们要选多少封信。100封，150封由真正花时间写作的真人写出的信。哦，多么特别。我在这本书里写得越少越好。因为我只是想用人们的话语来策划这本书。而且它也会是匿名的。
So, you know, you've got, again, like reasons to say, you've got these people out there in the world that have sat there and written this because they care. Also in the age of AI. God, a physical book with advice from real people. And we're, you know, very, it's very difficult because, you know, and this is a really good point. because a lot of people that have written letters on reason to stay have been AI.
所以，你知道的，你又会像《活下去的理由》里那样，拥有世界上这些坐在那里写下这些话的人，因为他们在乎。而且在这个人工智能（AI）的时代。天哪，一本包含来自真人建议的实体书。而且我们正在——你知道的，这非常困难，因为，你知道的，这是一个非常好的观点。因为很多在《活下去的理由》里写信的人其实是人工智能。
I may generally, maybe I should not mention this because maybe, but it's funny because AI has learned now what the perfect letter is for reasons to stay. So what's really interesting is you can tell it's from AI because it's all the same. So that Chagipiti has learned through lots and lots, thousands of people asking it this. It gives you the same letter. So although it sounds good, I know that that line. is the same in about 5,000 of, like there's a lot. So it's, and one thing, you know, the reason people turn to AI is because it's a difficult task.
我通常可能会——也许我不该提这个，因为也许，但这很有趣，因为AI现在已经学会了《活下去的理由》里完美的信件应该是什么样的。所以非常有趣的是，你可以一眼看出那是AI写的，因为它们都一模一样。所以ChatGPT已经通过成千上万、无数人向它询问此事，学会了这一点。它给你的信都是一样的。所以尽管它听起来不错，但我知道那句话在大概5000封信里都是一样的——有很多这样的情况。所以，而且有一件事，你知道的，人们求助于AI是因为这是一项艰巨的任务。
It's really, really hard to know what to say to someone. And that is the point. Like, it should feel hard. It should feel really difficult because in order to write a good letter to someone, you have to connect with something in you that feels that. The only way you can answer the question of, why should you not die, is understanding what you like about life.
要知道对某人说些什么真的是难上加难。这就是重点所在。这应该感觉很难。这应该感觉真的非常困难，因为为了给别人写一封好信，你必须与内心深处感受到那种情绪的自己产生连接。你回答“你为什么不该死”这个问题唯一的途径，就是理解你喜欢生活中的什么。
And there's something really difficult and special in that question. So, yeah, it's actually a really good point of like, if you're using AI, that defeats the point for you and for them, because it's not about, you know, reasons to stay is not about the words that are written. It's about the person that's written them and why. and if you know with AI it's just words but with a letter that's written by real human being actually the words matter less than the fact that you've spent the time doing it um so yeah no AI no AI no AI no AI in the book yeah yeah there are there are places in the word for AI
而那个问题中包含着非常困难且特别的东西。所以，是的，这其实是一个很好的观点，如果你在使用AI，那就违背了你和他们的初衷，因为这无关乎——你知道的，《活下去的理由》无关乎写下的字词。这关乎写下它们的人以及原因。如果你知道AI写出来的只是一些词句，但对于一封由真正的人类写就的信来说，字词本身其实并不那么重要，重要的是你为此花费了时间，嗯，所以，不，AI，不，AI，不，AI，书中绝不用AI。是的，是的，在这个世界上，AI信件有它们的一席之地，但在这种领域，它就是不行，那不是这么用的；所以，是的，我们现在非常擅长分辨哪些是AI写的，哪些是——我知道第一种感觉。我会遇到有人，对，我不展开讲了。但我总能看出什么时候，你会觉得：“哦，你可以看出来。”那不是真人。所以这本书将全都是真人写的。对。而且《活下去的理由》将永远都是真人写的。好吧，我们会在简介中留下预订链接。大家应该知道的一点是，图书预订是最重要的。哦，它们太重要了，因为它们基本上决定了谁会进货你的书。确实如此。对。所以这其实非常重要。因此请去预订，不要等到它出版再去买——尽管如果你愿意的话也可以等，但你可能还是应该去预订。
letters to people in this space it's just not that's just not it um so yeah it's we're getting very good at working out which one's AI and which ones are I know the first feeling. I get people, yeah, I won't go into it. But I can always tell when like, you're like, you can. That's not a real person. So this will be real people. Yeah. And the reason to say we'll always be real people. Well, we'll leave a link in the description to pre-order it. Something that people should know, pre-orders of books are the most important. Oh, they're so important because they basically drive who stocks you. Exactly. Yeah. So actually it's really important. So pre-order, don't wait for it to come out, although you can if you would like, but you probably should pre-order it.
你可以。可能需要等一会儿，因为我们还得整理校对这本书。哦，没关系。那会是一个美好的惊喜。这就是一个活下去的理由。对。因为你的书会通过邮寄送达。哦，千真万确。这绝对是真的。好的。最后一个问题。是的。我们对每一位嘉宾都会问这个问题。对于20多岁的人，你有什么建议是和我们今天聊的话题完全无关的？哇。哦，这真是个绝佳的观点。我想我们其实已经聊过这个了，但我真的是跑步的超级拥护者。
You can. It's a bit of a wait because we've got to compare the book. Oh, it's all right. That would be a nice surprise. It's a reason to stay. Yeah. Because your book will arrive in the mail. Yeah. Oh, that's so true. That's so true. Okay. Final question. Yes. We ask us of every single guest. What is one piece of advice you have for people in their 20s that has nothing to do with what we spoke about today? Wow. Oh, that's such a good point. I think we have spoken about it but I just am such an advocate for running
为了跑步——听起来可能很逊，因为如果我是三年前听到这话的人，我会觉得：“这简直是糟糕透顶的建议。”我读过一本书，一本了不起的书叫《天生就会跑》（Born to Run）。如果你想开始跑步但又还没完全下定决心，或者你从未真正享受过跑步，那就读读那本书。我说这话可没有拿一分钱版税。作者是谁？克里斯托弗·麦克杜格尔（Christopher McDougall）。他是美国的一名跑步记者，他基本上——他痴迷于这样一个观点：世界上有许多部落能够跑超级马拉松。有一个部落叫——我要把这个名字念错发音了——拉胡马拉（Tarahumara），塔拉胡马拉（Tamahumorah）
for running that sounds so lame because I would be listening to this like three years ago and I'd be like that is just terrible advice I read a book an amazing book called Born to Run if you are
在墨西哥，他们基本上为了好玩就能跑100英里，对吧？他基本上去了那里，他们穿着——他们举行这些比赛，穿着废弃汽车轮胎做的——用旧汽车轮胎做凉鞋，对吧？所以基本上我们这里穿着200英镑的泡沫跑鞋，却连5公里都跑得气喘吁吁，而他们literally（简直）穿着轮胎在跑。而且整本书
if you wanted to get into running but haven't quite or you never really enjoyed running read that book I don't earn anything from saying that. Who wrote it? Christopher McDougal. He's a running journalist in America and he basically, he's obsessed with the idea that there's lots of tribes around the world that can run ultramarathans. And there's one called, I'm going to mispronounce this, the Tarahumura, Tamahumorah
它并不完全是关于他们的，它基本上是关于人类是如何进化的，我们的进化史，以及我们以前是如何——我们的结构之所以是现在这样，我们的跟腱之所以有现在的大小，是因为我们天生就是为了跑步而设计的，并且能够在奔跑中进行有氧恢复。这是一本了不起的书，因为基本上——这听起来有点像我现在是个怪异的跑步狂了。不，这很对。它基本上让你意识到，实际上跑步对我们来说，有点像飞行对鸟儿一样。这就好像我们的基因里生来就注定能做到这一点。所以我爱极了这本书。
In Mexico, that basically, they run 100 miles for fun, right? And he basically goes there and they wear, they do these, races in um disused car tires sandals made from old car tires right so it's basically like we've got these like 200 pound foam shoes here and we struggle like 5k and they're they literally doing it in tires um and the whole book
我读了那本书，然后我决定报名参加一个超级马拉松。从那以后，跑步对我来说literally就是一切。而且最神奇的是，如果你去做了，如果你只是露面穿上运动鞋出门去跑，你会看到自己在进步，我觉得这本身就很棒。但你也会发现，这是一件神奇的事情，那就是对每个人来说，跑步的艰难程度永远都是一样的。
it's not all about them it's basically about how the human being evolved and our evolution and how we used to we are built the way we are our Achilles is the size it is because we are designed to run and be able to recover aerobically on the run. And it's an amazing book because basically, and this sounds a bit like I'm some weird runner now. No, it's right. It basically makes you realize actually running to us is a little bit like flying to a bird. And it's like we're so genetically wired into us to be able to do it. So I loved it.
无论是你从来没跑过步，还是你拼尽全力去跑，那种艰难的感觉永远是一样的。你可能会跑得更快，但那种感觉总是同样艰难。我觉得生活中真的没有什么事情是让所有人都有着“它有多难”这种普遍体验的。
I read that book and then I decided to sign up for an ultramarathon. And I literally running for me now is everything. And what's amazing as well is that if you do it, if you just show up and put your trainers on and get out of the door, you will see yourself improve, which I think is fantastic in itself. But you will also, it's an amazing thing, which is that it's always just as hard for everyone.
你可能会做不同的事情，但每个人的感受都是一样的。我觉得这相当特别。所以你不是在和任何人比赛。你永远都只是在提升自我。这是我开始做过的最好的事情之一。我太喜欢那本书了。去跑吧。
Like whether you've never run before, if you run as hard as you can, that's always as hard. You might run faster, but it always feels as hard. And I don't think there's anything really in life where everyone has the universal experience of how hard it is.
别把自己弄伤了。只要迈出家门就行。哪怕你必须走走跑跑、走走跑跑，你也只会觉得这是一项了不起的运动。真是个绝妙的建议。我怎么也想不到自己会对别人说出这种话。这就是我觉得人们开始跑步时会有的状态，他们会想：“天哪，这也太无聊了吧。”
You might do different things, but everyone feels the same. I think that's quite special. So you're not racing anyone. You're only ever improving yourself. It's one of the best things I ever started doing. I love that book. Run.
然后你开始跑了。你会觉得：“我懂了。”我想这是因为——不是要继续长篇大论如果我们要收尾的话——但我认为这是因为在学校里，跑步总是被当成一种惩罚。如果你说话，如果你在聊天，这就回到了经典条件反射。如果你在聊天，比如说，你会被罚绕着操场跑圈，或者这总是一件坏事。然后发生了一个美妙的时刻，萨姆，我只是说：“我打算去跑个步来离开家透透气。”然后我就再也没有停下来过。
Don't hurt yourself. Just get out the door. And even if you have to walk and run and walk and run, you just think it's a fantastic sport. Such great advice. I would never have imagined I'd say that to someone ever. This is the thing I think when people get into running, they're like, oh my God, it's so boring.
我就是爱极了。这是唯一能让我的——除了坐公共交通，说来也怪，那也是唯一能让我的大脑安静下来的时刻。我在公交车上时大脑真的很安静，我太喜欢了。从没想过这一点。是的。那是我想事情状态最好的地方。在公交车上？对。
And then you start doing it. And you're like, I get it. And I think it's because, not to go on if we're wrapping up, but I think it's because at school, running was always a punishment. Like if you talk, if you were talking, you come back to the classical conditioning. If you were talking, like, you'd be told to run around the field or like, it was always a bad thing. And then there was an amazing moment where losing something. Sam, I just went, I'm going to just go for a run to get out of the house. And then I just never stopped doing it.
在509路公交车上。《活下去的理由》灵感就是在公交车上产生的。哇。对，那是一次公交车之旅。我觉得以前这种地方应该是淋浴间，但现在我们在淋浴时听音乐。对，因为现在淋浴就是听音乐的时间。对，而且准备出门的过程，非常高度紧张。
I just love it. It's the only time my, that in public transport, weirdly, it's the only time my brain's ever quiet. My brain's really quiet on the bus, which I love it. Never thought about that. Yeah. It's where I do my best, like, thinking. On the bus? Yeah.
而且准备出门的过程，非常，对，非常，压力山大。公交车。就是这样。坐着伦敦的超级环线（Super Loop）兜风吧。超级环线？对。我可不干。不。
On the 509. I've had reasons to stay came on a bus. Wow. Yeah, that was a bus journey. I feel like that used to be the shower, but now we listen to music in the show. Yeah, because showers are just music now. Yeah. And getting ready, very high.
我这辈子再也不想在这个城市的任何公共交通上待着了。我可能还得坐。我觉得所有的地铁都坏了。我觉得我得坐公交车回去了。哦，天哪。好吧，谢谢你来做客。谢谢你邀请我。对。
And getting very, yeah, very, like, stressful. Bus. There we go. Ride the super loop around London. The super loop? Yeah. I'm not going to do that. No.
谢谢你加入我们的播客。谢谢你的分享。我们会在简介中留下所有内容的链接。关于《活下去的理由》，这本书，你可以看到本最近在忙些什么。他一直在做一些非常酷的事情，真的是太酷了，居然和威廉王子是好哥们儿。所以我期待他很快能在上面发一张自拍。不过，再次谢谢你。如果你坚持听到了这里，请在下方留下一个小白色心形表情符号，好让我们知道你一直听到了最后并且喜欢这一集。和往常一样，我们在Netflix上也提供完整剧集，
I don't want to be on any more public transport in this city ever again. I might have to. I think all the tubes are broken. I think I'm going to be on the bus back. Oh, dang. Well, thanks for coming on. Thank you for having me. Yeah.
如果你想去观看这次访谈或我们未来的对话。我也会在下方的简介中留下链接。那里总是有很多东西可以去探索和进一步了解。所以下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快就会再聊。快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。但现在有一种全新且令人兴奋的方式，可以开启你迈向更快乐生活旅程的序幕：《欢乐101》。
Thanks for joining us on the podcast. Thanks for sharing. We're going to leave links in the description to everything. reasons to stay, the book, you can see what Ben's up to. He's doing some really cool stuff, always, which is so cool, being best buddies with Prince William. So I expect a selfie on there from him soon. But yeah, thank you again. If you have made it this far, leave a little white heart emoji down below, just so that we know that you've listened all the way to the end and that you enjoyed this episode. As always, we also have full episodes on Netflix,
这是一个由我——霍达·科特比主持的全新播客。如果你渴望获得将快乐最大化的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中聊天。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio App。搜索《欢乐101》（Joy 101），立即收听。《霍达的欢乐101》由 CVS 倾情呈现。它刚刚上线。杰里米，你刚刚做了什么？
If you want to go and watch this talk or future conversations that we have. I'll also leave links in the description down below. There's always a bunch of stuff to go and explore and go into further down there. So until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101.
你这是在自掘坟墓啊。我从来没听你讲过这个故事。我从来没讲过这个故事。这个故事一定深藏在杰里米·林（Jeremy Lynn）记忆的最深处。我的名字是 MC Jin（欧阳靖）。我很高兴向大家介绍《笑到最后》（laugh but not least）。我将与各行各业的嘉宾畅聊幽默在面对艰难困苦时的力量。
It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free I-Heart Radio app. Search Joy 101, and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda-Kotby is presented by CVS. It just came out. Jeremy, what did you just do?
这些对话将提醒我们所有人：生活艰难，笑得更灿烂。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方，收听由 MC Jin 主持的《笑到最后》。祝直言不讳播客网络（Outspoken Podcast Network）的骄傲月（Pride）快乐。整个月乃至全年，我们都在庆祝自己声音洪亮、引以为傲且始终独一无二。
You just sit yourself up for failure. I've never heard you tell this story. I've never told this story. This must have been tucked deep, deep into Jeremy Lynn, My name is MC Jin. I'm excited to tell you about laugh but not least. I'll be chatting with guests from all walks of life about the power of humor when it comes to facing difficult times.
我是布兰登·凯尔·古德曼（Brandon Kyle Goodman），播客《告诉我一些凌乱的事》（Tell Me Something Messy）的主持人。收听我的节目，获取关于约会、人际关系和成人生存法则的无滤镜看法。收听《High Key》获取最佳流行文化观点，还有《互联网上没有女孩》（There Are No Girls On The Internet）了解你所有的科技新闻。想要了解你最喜欢的名人八卦（key keys），请收听 T.S.马迪森（T.S. Madison）的《法律》（Outlaws）。通过《BFF, Black Fat Fem》学会毫无歉意地爱自己。并在七月即将到来的《与瑞安一起醒来》（Waking up with Ryan）中以满满的意图开启新的一天。与直言不讳网络（Outspoken Network）共同庆祝骄傲月。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。
These will be conversations that remind us all, life is hard, laugh harder. Listen to laugh but not least with MCJN on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Happy pride from the Outspoken Podcast Network. All month long and all year round, we're celebrating being loud, proud, and always original.
搜索“Pride”并立即收听。在这个黑人音乐月，《奎斯特拉夫秀》（The Questlove Show）旨在致敬那些通过声音塑造文化的远见者。从乡村音乐开拓者米基·盖顿（Mickey Guyton）到嘻哈偶像五代弗雷迪（Fab 5 Freddie），还有雷鸣猫（Thundercat）的音乐天才之声，以及查克·D（Chuck D）的革命性嗓音。
It's me, Brandon Kyle Goodman, host of the podcast, Tell Me Something Messy. Check out my show for unfiltered takes on dating, relationships, and adulting. Listen to High Key for the best pop culture takes, and there are no girls on the internet for all your tech news. For your favorite celebrity key keys, check outlaws with T.S. Madison. Learn to love yourself unapologetically with BFF, Black Fat Fem. And start your day with intention with waking up with Ryan coming in July. Celebrate Pride with the Outspoken Network. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
我希望声音响亮。所以节奏可能有点不准，声音可能有点沉闷，但从那里传出来的将是你能真切感受到的一些东西。通过《奎斯特拉夫秀》的特别单集来庆祝黑人音乐月。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方收听。
Search Pride and listen now. This Black Music Month, The Quest Love Show celebrates the visionaries, shaping culture through sound. From Country Trailblazer Mickey Gaiden to hip-hop icon Fad 5 Freddie, the sonic genius of Thundercat, and the revolutionary voice of Chuck Deere.
欢迎来到《萨巴拉足球》（Sabara Football），感受球场内外那些甜蜜与辛辣的故事。我是达妮埃拉·杜兰（Daniella Durand），在这里，我们将前所未有地走近这项运动背后的那些人。压力、名气，以及当摄像机关闭时发生的一切。尽情享受与诸如巴尔巴特拉（Barbartra）、埃纳德（Ennard）、查尔顿·埃斯科巴（Charlton Escobar）、波约莱津（Poyolezine）、费代雷拉（Federeira）等众多嘉宾的对话吧。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方收听《萨巴拉足球》。这是一个 iHeart 播客，真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
I want it loud. So the timing might be off, the sound might be muffled, but what's going to come out of there is something that you can feel. Celebrate Black Music Month with special episodes of the Questlove show. Listen on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我希望声音很大。所以时间可能不太对，声音可能听起来很闷，但从那里传出来的将是你能感受到的东西。通过 Questlove 秀的特别节目来庆祝黑人音乐月。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Welcome to Sabara Football, the sweet and the spicy on and off the field. I'm Daniela Durand, and this is where we get to know the people behind the game like never before. The pressure, the fame, and everything that happens when the cameras turn off. Enjoy conversations with guests like Barbartra, Ennard, Charlton Escobar, Poyolezine, Federeira, and many more. Listen to Zawara football on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
欢迎来到 Sabara Football，这里有场内场外的甜蜜与火辣。我是 Daniela Durand，在这里我们将前所未有地走近比赛背后的传奇人物。压力、名气，以及摄像机关闭后发生的一切。与 Barbartra、Ennard、Charlton Escobar、Poyolezine、Federeira 等众多嘉宾展开精彩对话。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Zawara football。这是一个 iHeart 播客，绝对由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。